okay
is your witness out there is a witness
out there he's down the hall judge
all right bringing the jury in
so
all right be seated everyone morning
ladies and gentlemen of the jury hope
everyone had a good evening we're going
to continue with the trial
we're going to resume with the testimony
of detective bailly officer can you
bring in detective bailey please
all right somebody's got a mute
your computer please
it's not just muted it's the sound has
to be on completely
muted and the sound has to be turned off
i'll take care of them
sorry
yes
all right because of the break will we
swear detective bailly please place your
left hand on the bible raise your right
hand do you swear in the presence of
almighty god that the testimony just to
this point regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth yes please state your name
i'll spell your last name for the record
detective brian bailey t-a-i-l-e-y
thank you
thank you detective have a seat please
keep your voice up nice and loud again
if you don't understand the question
please indicate that off council
rephrase
we'll resume the testimony the direct
testimony of detective bailly go ahead
mr shellhorn
thank you honor
good morning detective good morning
i think yesterday we concluded your
testimony talking about some articles of
clothing that you recovered from the
rear of the farmhouse yes
and you had identified two articles of
clothing that you recovered near the
stairway
a red and black shirt s182 and a yellow
sweatshirt s183 yes
did you collect any other clothing from
outside the farmhouse area in the yard
yes
and what was that
uh a red nike polo shirt
and uh judge
i'd like permission to display
a photo
it's s216
it has been moved into evidence
very well what's your number
216.
detective i know we were just here
yesterday but you can just reorient the
jury uh to 216
and what the vantage point of this photo
is
that's the rear of the residence just
off the driveway to the back a little
bit and that is the white trailer where
mr barristone was when i arrived on
scene
and i think you indicated yesterday that
he was in that area receiving attention
from some medical folks that's correct
are you aware that certain articles of
clothing or items of potential
evidentiary value were left in the area
when mr barrison was removed from the
scene yes
and i'm going to direct your attention
next to s250 and evidence
what is s250 a picture of
that is a picture of the clothing
located near mr barrison and uh
was the condition of the clothing in
that area the same as the condition of
the clothing that you recovered in the
back of the farmhouse yes and can you
tell the jury what that was
that is uh the condition of clothing was
saturated with soaking wet um
and it was the the red shirt and the
shoes
and i'm gonna direct your attention i
think it's on the desk in front of you
there to what s 186 what is s186 it's
the red nike polo shirt
and uh how can you tell that that's the
red nike polo shirt it's in the bag uh
that i collected it in
judge at this point i'd like to move
s-186 into evidence and show it to the
jury
any objection
186
red nike shirt
be accepted into evidence it may be
displayed to the jurors go ahead
detective
all right detective you removed the uh
shirt from the bag does that appear to
be in the same or substantially the same
condition although it's dry now as when
you recovered it on august 7 2019 yes
and uh if you could judge with your
permission if the detective could walk
it down in front of the jury into the
gallery showing
the front on the first pass and then the
back on the second pass
certainly go ahead detect it
i guess for purposes of the record it
would be the uh the outside of the shirt
because it's cut on the first pass and
that will be the inside of the shirt on
the second pass
thank you detective you can put that
back into the bag
yes
judge i just handed forward to detect
the daily s-179
s-180 and s-181
those were items of evidence recovered
at the scene
alas that they be admitted at this time
so the detective can shut them
right s 179 180 181
will be admitted into evidence
i believe 181 is already in evidence but
i believe that's true
179 and 180 will be admitted
detective bailey at some point while you
were in the area of the scene i know
that you had indicated that you marked
certain items of evidence with uh
placards correct
and i'm going to draw your attention
first
to s207
we're just pulling it up
i believe you testified to this photo
yesterday correct
again just uh for purposes of the record
can you reorient the jury to the angle
or the vantage point that s 207 is from
this is a mid-range photograph located
in the driveway of a placard number two
that is covering a
potential piece of evidence in this case
a shell casing
and is that placard uh the larger
placard covering this the smaller
placard
yes
um the director attention to s
234 what is s234 a picture of
that's a picture of a shell casing and
which placard is next to that shell
casing a number one and you see that in
this photo yes where is it
top right of the
photo was there any significance to the
numbers of the placards that you placed
down on the various pieces of evidence
no they were just used as reference
points for photographs
now the shell casing that we're looking
at uh in s-234
did you collect that shell casing yes
and do you see it in front of you marked
as s-179
yes
if you would
please just remove that and show it to
the jury
this might be tough to open
now detective you uh testified that
that's a shell casing correct based on
your training education experience what
is a shell casing the shell casing is
uh when it's fully intact it's a bullet
when it's discharged from a weapon a
firearm
it's now a discharge shell casing
so i'm sure we'll have more testimony
about ballistics later on in the trial
but uh are you saying that when a bullet
is shot out of a gun the projectile
comes from the front of the barrel while
this is ejected from the ejector port
and you located that in the area of the
driveway behind the farmhouse yes
all right thank you
next i'll direct your attention uh to s
and 204
and what is s 204 a picture of uh it's a
mid-range photograph of another placard
two um in the back patio area the
driveway and i believe you testified to
this photo as well yesterday
that you took this photo
just after it started raining correct
direct your attention to s-236
what is s-236 a picture of it's a
picture of the shell casing that is
located underneath the
fire debris can with the evidence marker
on top of it
and can you remind the jury why you went
back and put that can over the top of
the shell casing with the weather that
we were getting and the amount of rain
that we got in such a little bit of time
i decided to use fire debris cans to
kind of
dig them around the shell casings so we
wouldn't lose any potential evidence
was that fire debris can used or was it
new brand new
next i'll show you two s237
what is s237 a picture of uh spent shell
casing
and uh would this be the same shell
casing that you just indicated you had
originally marked with marker number two
yes
can you describe
obviously you know we're looking at the
picture but can you describe where that
shell casing was found and what the
condition was
uh the shell casing was found in the
rear of the driveway
just off to the to the left um in the
grass area
but being with the water it was
slowly getting submerged in water so
that's why we preserved it and covered
it
and you have s 180 in front of you
correct what is s-180 it is that shell
casing
did you collect that shell casing yes
did you put it into that envelope yes
and if you could just uh remove it from
the envelope and show it to the jury
thank you detective
after you collected the shell casings as
well as all the evidence you collected
where did you take it it was secured
into the command post um that was
located on scene and when we were clear
from the scene those pieces of evidence
were then transported back to the crime
lab and secured in the evidence room
and at some point are you aware whether
certain evidence were submitted either
within your agency or to other agencies
for further examination yes
do you know if those shell casings were
ultimately given to someone from your
agency for examination yes they were
and do you know who that was yes who was
that forensic examiner bill stitt
now i'm going to show you next s
239
what is s239 a picture of
uh it's a mid-range of the rear of the
driveway
slowly coming into the back of the
residence with the evidence placard
number one marking a uh magazine
and again was there any significance to
these placards no uh what do we see in
the top right of the
[Music]
picture
uh
in between the i guess the
the truck and the uh
those white items
what's the yellow item in the top right
there
those are the evidence placards that
were marking the shell casings in the
driveway and would that have been shell
casing the first one that you showed
s179 yes
all right so with respect to the item
that we're looking at in the foreground
of this picture i'm going to direct your
attention to s240
what is s240 a picture of a magazine
and what is a magazine
magazine is what contains the cartridges
for a handgun
this is a close-up photo of the magazine
that you located in that grassy area yes
were there any bullets located inside of
this magazine no
i believe that's already been moved into
evidence as well you have s181 in front
of you yes
is s181 the magazine that you recovered
from that grassy area yes
and how do you know that oh it's in the
bag that i put it in
is your handwriting on the back yes
right detective when you were uh
finished
searching the area of the uh
the farmhouse and processing that area
did you search and process any other
areas of the property yes uh then
proceeded up to the dressage area
process the clubhouse in the office
all right detective bailey i'm showing
you what's been marked as s 301 in
evidence what is s 301 a picture of uh
that's an overall the entrance working
our way into the office
so this would be coming into the office
from where the clubhouse
and i'm going to show you what's been
marked as s302
what is s302 a picture of that's after
we entered and photographing our way
back towards where we came from
with these photographs taken before you
have conducted your search correct
what is on the right hand side of that
picture s 302 oh i see
did you search that safe yes
did you recover a number of items from
within the office area yes and did those
items include certain electronic devices
and uh various paperwork yes were those
all uh marked as evidence and then
logged into evidence yes in the same
method that you described earlier yes
all right i'm gonna ask you some
questions about uh searching the safe
um i'm gonna show you s 303 in evidence
what is s303 a picture of oh that's an
overall of the safe
and was the safe
in that condition meaning the door was
closed when you got into the room yes
was it unlocked i believe so
and you were able to open the door and
get into it yes
right next i'll show you s304
what is that 304 a picture of uh that's
an overall photograph of the inside of
the content
and is that a fair and accurate picture
of the contents of the safe before you
conducted any search yes meaning that
that's how the items all appeared when
you first opened the safety yes
judge if i could have permission to
approach
certainly
[Music]
um
all right detective did you collect a
number of items that were located in
that scene yes
and if you could just describe for the
jury
what some of the items that we can see
in the picture as 304 are
there's a pink and black gun case um
there's a and where is that that's on
the located on the top shelf
and what's next to that pink and black
orange uh plink and black gun case there
is a dummy magazine located directly to
the right of that pink and black case
can you tell the jury what a dummy
magazine is dummy magazine you can't put
any rounds in any bullets in and that
would go into a weapon to keep the
weapon safe
what would be
those items that are located to the back
left on the top shelf behind the pink
and black gun case those are various
different types of ammunition
and did you uh were you there when that
ammunition was cataloged yes
moving down to the next shelf below that
on the on the left hand side of the
safe what are those items on the
left-hand side those are rifles
and were you there when those items were
collected by the washington township
police
i wasn't physically in the room but
during that night yes
um to the right of that on that
second shelf down in the very center of
the picture what is that uh item that
looks black and copper
that is a box of nine millimeter rounds
and what is behind those that box of
nine millimeter rounds
there is two revolvers and one
semi-automatic angle
all right detective i had handed up a
number of items just now uh s 306 is one
of the items excuse me s190 is one of
the items that i have handed forward and
i'm going to show you
a picture s306
what is s 306 a picture of that's a box
uh containing nine millimeter rounds
and did you uh
photograph that as it was when you open
the safe yes
can you describe the condition of that
box in the state of that box when you
open the safe
the box was partially opened
what we're looking at the back of the
photo or the middle of the photo the
back of the box was slightly torn and
was open until approximately the fourth
row of bullets
and i think um
to your left there there is a pointer
that we tried charging last night i
don't know if it will work on this
picture but if you could just point out
to the jury
can i stand
yes yes
uh can you see it
yeah
it's uh so the box was was partially
open
ripped up at the top here um if you can
see me circling on it trying to do my
best
but um it was also open until
approximately the the fourth row of
bullets like midway
and you did you collect that box of
bullets yes and do you see that box in
front of you or do you see a package uh
an item of evidence s190 yes what is
s190 s190 is the
box of ammunition nine millimeter rounds
the same
ammunition that we're looking at
yes could you open that please
hold on that's not in evidence yet are
you moving it into evidence i'm sorry
judge i thought when i handed them
forward i asked them to be in evidence i
apologize
i'm not sure you gave the numbers
judge i had handed forward s-190
okay
all right s190s and evidence go ahead
detective judge mike just at the same
time ask for s-191
s-202
s-199
s-200
and s-201
any objection to those items
mr blenkis
those items are in evidence you may uh
stand up and show the item to the jurors
detective if i could ask that you could
open that box uh
carefully
and pull out the
tray with the the bullets in it and then
judge if i could ask that that could be
walked around to show the jury the
condition of approximately how far open
it was at the time the detectives
searched the city certainly go ahead
detective
bless you
uh
thank you detective billy if you can put
that back into the envelope
[Music]
detective we're pulling up next s305
what is that a picture of it's a picture
of a pink and black uh gun case and
located directly to the right of that is
the dummy magazine
now what was the and you
took this photograph before you
collected those items yes uh what was
the condition or state of the black and
pink
uh
gun case it was it was open
and and how does it open and close with
a zipper
do you see in front of you
s-191
yes
and if i could ask that that has been
moved into evidence if i could ask you
to open that to show the jury
and is that currently open or closed
open could you uh
open it for the jury and
show the inside
detective billy what is the blue uh
plastic item that's inside the gun case
these are typically used to
stick through the barrel
or up through the the chamber to make
the weapon safe and it's basically a
flag so
somebody else would know the weapon is
safe as well
and that was inside of the gun case when
you collect it correct was there any
other item or items inside the gun case
when you collected it no
thank you
now you indicated in s305 that there was
also an orange dummy magazine next to
the case correct
i'm going to direct your attention to
s202
which i think you have in front of you
yes
are you aware if that item was collected
by the washington township police yes
and i'm going to ask you to open s-202
and that has been moved into evidence so
i would ask if you could
judge again if this could be walked down
and shown to the jury back in the
gallery certainly go ahead
detective detected if you could just
show
one side on the first pass and then the
second side on the next pass
um
uh detective you indicated that there
were a number of other guns located uh
in the safe that's correct and were
those uh taken
into the custody of the washington
township police department that's
correct yes
did you have a chance to look at those
firearms before they were taken yes were
any of them loaded to your recollection
no
now you indicated that there were a
number of uh rifles or long guns on the
left-hand side correct do you recall
approximately how many uh three
and was there any ammunition for
those guns
yes
and i think you indicated there was uh
some ammunition on the top left-hand
shelf
uh which is shown in s304 yes
do you remember how how many handguns
there were inside the safe
there was three
two revolvers and a semi-automatic
and i'll ask you first i think you have
those all on the
ground next to you but i'll move judge
if i can just remove some of these other
items certainly
i'll take these items out of your way
detective bailey we'll start with s-199
do you have s-199 in front of you yes
what is that
this is a
revolver
pistol
and you uh know what caliber that was
i believe it's a 22.
s-199 is that the full 45
this is the colt 45 yes i'm sorry
are you aware whether there was any 45
caliber ammunition in the states there
was not
um judge this has been moved into
evidence i'd like permission to show
this item to the jury
all right certainly go ahead detective
199.
yes
and it may be easier
to walk it around if that's our job
that's fine
so
detective i don't think i asked you this
question but are those guns in the same
or substantially the same condition as
when you saw them the night of august 7
2019 aside from the fact that they may
have safety mechanisms on them at this
point yes
next i'm going to draw your attention to
s200
do you have that in front of you yes
what is s200
it is a semi-automatic uh handgun
and do you know what uh caliber that was
i believe this is a 380. was there any
380 caliber ammunition located in the
safe no
judge with the court's permission i'd
like to show s 200 to the jury
certainly go ahead detective
you may display it to the jurors
okay
so
detective the last item i'm going to ask
you about is
s201
if you have s201 in front of you yes
what is s201
it is a revolver
do you know what caliber it is uh 22.
and was there any 22 caliber ammunition
in the state yes
judge with the court's permission i'd
like to show have the detective show s
201 to the jury yes go ahead you may
step down and display it to the jury
living
detective bailey are you aware whether
those items were
provided to
forensic examiner stitch in the morris
county sheriff's office yes
judge i want to meet you further
questions at this time for detective
daily all right very good close
examination
[Music]
good morning detective good morning sir
your job basically and correctly if i'm
wrong
was to
secure the scene
and protect
and document
all potential evidence correct correct
now
when you got to the scene
would you agree with me that it was
chaotic
yes um
40 50 people running around doing
different things correct i'm not sure on
the number of people
how many would you estimate i'm not sure
three
first
here
my approach
so i'm going to show you 11-1
which is the crime scene log for sure
first of all can you explain to the
ladies and jury what a crime scene lodge
is
yes the crime scene log is basically um
a log that somebody's going to be taking
to document who's coming in and out of
that scene
so we have a record of times um in and
out basically of what their friends
whether it's a police officer whether
it's emergency medical services um
anybody that would be entering the scene
and were you the person in control of
that law no
can you take a look at that log
and see if that refreshes your
recollection as
to whether or not there were
approximately 40 to 50 different people
in and out of that crime scene
there's numerous people throughout
throughout the night
when you say
numerous
in excess of 50 people correct
i can count
don't don't count just does it refresh
your memory yes
i would say so okay thank you what was
your answer
of approximately 40 people
thank you
[Music]
what was that exhibit number
1100-1 defense
so
um
when you got to the scene
would you agree with me that it was not
secured
yes it was not secured yet it was still
an active scene
and
it was your job at that point upon your
arrival to secure the same scene and
protect all the evidence correct
i responded to this scene as a law
enforcement officer again it came across
the radio as an active shooter so i
responded as a essentially a police
officer
when i arrived on scene my role as a law
enforcement officer was still in play
being that i am crime scene-minded i did
realize that there was potential
evidence on the scene
and i documented that evidence or
preserve try to preserve that evidence
to the best of my ability
while everything was still
very chaotic
okay and and after
was no longer chaotic
you were in control of
securing all of the potential evidence
correct correct
and you indicated yesterday that in
order to do your job
you need to
talk to the officers
to find out what happened
which allows you to take certain
precautions with regards to securing
evidence correct correct
for instance you were aware that it was
that a gun was used correct correct and
you were told and told a specific number
of shots potentially had been fired
correct correct i believe so correct
how many shots
were you told or fired i believe it was
a approximately three three shots
okay and uh would you agree with me that
every time
a nine million millimeter gun discharges
a bullet a casing is discharged
correct
how many casings
did you
find and preserve
during your search
two
one's missing correct correct
now
were you aware that there was a video
camera
on the side of the house that
potentially could have captured the
entire incident yes did you preserve
that video
at that time
no based off of uh process
did you preserve it no
was the prosecutor's office there and
also aware that there was a video camera
that potentially could have preserved
don't don't answer that question
you're asking his knowledge of what
other people knew at the time
yeah you said if the prosecutor's office
knew
that's their state of mind
rephrase the question
or withdrawn and ask another one
was the morris county prosecutor's
office or any representative from that
office
at the crime scene
on that night while you were doing your
job yes
now
on that day
you find both a handgun
two casings
and
two magazines correct correct
and those are the ones that have been
introduced into evidence correct correct
and
um judge i don't believe that's accurate
no it's not the testimony
rephrase your question okay you found
the handgun correct correct
you
we've introduced into evidence one
magazine correct correct
and two shell casings correct correct
okay as a crime scene investigator
do those items potentially have
fingerprints
and dna on them yes
were they submitted to
a fingerprint expert and or a dna expert
at any time to your knowledge no
now
you indicated that when you got there
and first
were able to appraise the scene
it was not raining correct correct
you indicated yesterday that
you were waiting for a search warrant
correct correct
and at some point in time
you received a search warrant correct
correct which allowed you to search
basically everything that
you requested on that warrant correct
correct
for instance
you were able to search my client's
vehicle correct correct
in the photographs introduced by the
prosecutor there were two other vehicles
and a trailer
in the immediate area do you recall
seeing them yes
are you aware of the fact that they
belong to robert goodwin i don't
did you or anyone to your knowledge
get a search warrant
to search those vehicles which were
included in your crime scene area
i did not and to my knowledge i don't
know
where was robert goodwin when you
arrived when i arrived he was located in
front of the police one of the police
vehicles that was parked in the driveway
now
the prosecutors introduced
numerous photographs of telephones that
were on the scene correct correct
there's one on the uh
it's like a round
table correct
are you aware of the fact that that's my
client's telephone i was not at the time
now
there were two other phones located on
an umbrella base at the bottom of the
stairs correct correct
and they were basically
on top of each other correct correct
and when you first got to the scene
um
you
photographed those items in the exact
location that they were found correct
correct and then you tried to protect
them
because of the rain with plastic correct
yes
now with with regards to uh clothing
that's been introduced into evidence by
the prosecutor
specifically the yellow sweatshirt and
red t-shirt
with the bullet defects in them
upon seeing them
you were aware that they belonged to
the alleged victim correct yes
and
would you agree with me that
you believed it was important to
preserve them
correct yes
because
certain evidential things can be
had from those items of clothing correct
correct
now in the warrant it indicated that you
were able
to take samples of my client's hands for
gunshot residue correct correct
now
gunshot residue
is
basically
gun powder
which is expelled both from
the weapon towards the back
which would
get on a person's hand and from the
front
which potentially could get on someone's
clothing correct correct
so the
gunshot residue basically goes in both
directions when a weapon is filed
correct correct
now
in the warren
you were given permission
to
swab my client's hands
to make a determination if he had any
gunshot residue
on his hands correct correct
did you or anyone to your knowledge
request to do the same thing
on either lauren cataract's
or robert goodwin's hands
not to my knowledge
with regards to the clothing
were you aware that lauren cataract has
indicated that she was shot at close
distance yes
did anyone to your knowledge
conduct gunshot residue
evaluations on her clothing
to either confirm or verify
that she was shot at close range yes
and what were the results of that hold
on
did he do it
no
you can't answer that then it's hearsay
i withdraw what he did do it judge i'm
sorry he did do it what hold on
say that again
this witness did it yes oh all right
then it can answer
i thought he said no that he didn't do
i think i think the question was about
whether there was any swabbings of
anyone's hands no no
no that's not what he he was asking the
follow-up question the results of an
examination
that was done to the clothing
well he could tell what the results were
but he didn't do the test
we did do the test it was negative
let me see at cyborg
rephrase your question please and set a
foundation for us please
sir
are you an expert with regards to
he's not qualified as an expert
no but no are you going to you can't ask
a question if he's an expert and have
him say yes without qualifying him as an
expert to render an opinion if that's
what you want to do with him
then qualify him as an expert you can't
just ask him if he's an expert without
qualifying him and ask him his opinion
why are you asking him if he's an expert
an expert has a specific
designation under the law
if you're going to ask him that as an
expert you have to qualify him as an
expert otherwise don't ask him if he's
an expert
i'm not sure
raise your question please
officer do you have training with
regards to uh
examination examining gunshot rescue
i have training using an infrared camera
and what results would look like
and where did you get that trainer
through fujifilm and how long was that
training
um to my knowledge it was an eight-hour
club eight-hour course so so basically
you've had eight hours of training
correct eight hours of training correct
and the method
that you
is what in this case i used a fujifilm
xt
100 i believe camera infrared uv camera
to photograph the items with different
lens filters to produce different
results
okay and
is there more a more sophisticated
method to your knowledge
to make that determination to my
knowledge they could be tested with a
presumptive test
and what's a presumptive test what do
you mean by that it's a chemical based
test that you could um
basically swab
onto the item and see if there is
potential
results and would you agree that that
technique is far
more
accurate and reliable than just the
test that you get no
now
does the fact that the clothing was
drenched have any impact on the test
that you did
it could have an impact on any test to
be conducted
if our tests showed that there was any
um
presence of any gsr what we would have
done is then used a presumptive test or
sent that out into the lab
and you did it with regards to uh
miss cataract's clothing correct correct
did you do it with regards to
my client's clothing no
when you say did it you're referring to
the um using the camera right yeah yes
all right you understand that's what he
was talking about yes
now
there was a
bullet hole
in the door
by the back stairs correct correct
did you see where that bullet went to
can you rephrase that
did you see where that bullet went to i
saw where the bullet struck the door and
the potential flight path of that
projectile yes
and
would you agree with me that the bullet
went
through the room
and threw a window
to the left or the right of the door
i believe that yes the flight path that
projectile did go out an exit window
did you ever find that
spent bullet
we did not find that projectile did you
look for it yes
did you use metal detectors to attempt
to find it
not that particular projectile based on
the flight path
so
you have no idea what caliber
bullet
caused that
defect in the door
and or the window and it went through
correct
and you are missing one
at least one case incorrect correct
now
those
items of clothing lauren cataract
i believe you testified there were a
entrance and an exit defect correct
that's correct which would indicate to
you that the
bullet went
through her
and her clothing correct that's correct
did you find
those bullets no we did not
now
the
clubhouse area
the prosecutor has showed you uh
photographs of the office area correct
that's correct
and the door to that office area is a
solid
wooden door correct
i believe so yes
and
when you walk into the office that's
safe that you've
testified to about is on your left
correct correct
the safe was closed but it wasn't locked
correct correct
and
i know you've testified to
that
pink and black case
and items associated with that um there
were in fact other weapons in there
correct that's correct
and there was for instance a 22
revolver yes with ammunition yes
and there were numerous long guns
including a shotgun correct yes
boxes of shotgun shells that fit those
particular weapons correct right
sure
redirect mr shellhorn
yes john
[Music]
detective bailey are you aware whether
any metal detectors were used at the
scene
to look for
other shell casings or projectiles no
detectors were used on the scene yes and
was that on august 7th or august 8th or
something else
uh it could have been in between on both
days based off the circumstances of the
scene i don't know what time of night or
day
but you're aware they were used they
were used correct
have you ever
do you have any experience with uh shell
casings being ejected from a bullet from
personal experience in terms of your
experience shooting at the range and
that sort of thing yes have you ever
investigated any other shooting
incidents yes
so you have practical experience with
investigating
shooting incidents where there were
shell casings yes
do you have any experience with other
investigations or personal experience as
uh as a police officer
with what could happen to a shell casing
or how it gets ejected from a gun yes
can you explain that to the jury
showcases get ejected from a weapon um
it's not
repetition it's not the same every time
also um
being a police officer shooting on the
range i have come home with showcasings
in my boots stuck to my boots so they
are
able to
get places basically where you're
stepping on them in your clothing where
they're not going to be
in the direct vicinity of where that
weapon was fired
now you indicated that when you got to
the scene on august 7
2019 it was not raining yet correct
how would you describe the rain
that did come down that afternoon
uh it was substantial it was very heavy
and it came very quick
and can you estimate
could you estimate approximately how
long after you got on scene that the
rain started
i would say approximately within 25 to
30 minutes of arriving on scene the rain
started
and
became very heavy at times
and during that time were there still
individuals on the scene
either rendering medical assistance to
some of the people or trying to clean up
um
i don't believe anybody was still on
scene
receiving any medical treatment at that
time
i'm going to show you again what's been
marked as
s 205.
s205 i think you had testified earlier
was a picture of one of the shell
casings in the driveway yes or the area
of one of the shell cases yes
can you see the shell casing in this
picture no why not uh it's submerged in
water
and
is this picture representative of other
areas on that driveway or in that yard
at the time that you uh
noticed the rain starting yes
if you were asked a question about
whether you were aware if there was any
sort of a camera
at the house the day that you were
processing yes
um
and i think you were asked if you knew
that was there and if you collected it
yes um can you explain to the jury uh
what your
role was or what you knew about that
that camera based on your experience as
a crime scene officer based on my
experience as a crime scene detective
the camera was photographed there
we did examine that camera
on scene it was a cloud-based system so
that physical camera itself wouldn't be
storing any of our our data any of our
video it would be going to a cloud
for example like a ring
ring is very common and it's a
cloud-based system so you can log into
your account
basically from a computer a phone a
tablet and you can kind of look at
what's been going on through your cloud
and would that be something that you
and have you do you have experience with
those type of cameras based on your
experience as a crime scene investigator
uh yes then personal
[Music]
i think the last question i had for you
was you were asked if you had had
photographed
any of the defendant's clothes
that you collected or processed those
with the ir camera for gunshot residue
i was asked that question yes now you
indicated that you did process uh lauren
canorex clothing first yes what was the
reason you chose to
process those articles of clothing first
so when those articles were dried um we
did we did know that
miss cameron act did receive two
gunshots
so after those those articles of
clothing were dried throughout the
drying chamber they were then
photographed so we could see the defects
that night um during the actual crime
scene investigation we weren't able to
see those defects based on how saturated
and how wet the clothing was so when
they were taken back and dried then they
were examined for for defects
and with respect to the ir camera and
the looking for the gunshot residue is
there a reason that you chose her
articles of clothing to check first yes
we did know that those articles of
clothing after examining them with our
our eyes and a normal photography with
our normal typical crime scene camera we
noticed bullet defects so that's when we
did use the ir camera to examine those
articles of clothing with different
lights and filters and based on not re
identifying any gunshot residue on those
articles of clothing did that influence
your decision not to photograph other
items jackson leading it was a little
bit leading mr shellhorn just that
rephrase your question based on your uh
examination of those articles of
clothing meaning ms canorax did that
impact your investigation
yes uh being that we had negative
results with our our ir camera um no
other clothing was then photographed
utilizing that ir camera
judge i don't have any further questions
thank you what
any um requests briefly
based on your experience
with
casings being
ejected from a
handgun
would you agree that wherever they
are pretty unreliable and unpredictable
as to
as to where they land
yes
and
before you got there
with the number of people
could those specific casings that you've
identified and marked as pieces of
evidence could they have been disturbed
in all the chaos
which would have made those locations
unreliable yes
so based on your experience would you
agree with me
that it would be almost impossible to
make a determination as to where someone
was standing
when the weapon was fired based on
where you marked those cases being found
that's correct
nothing further all right you may step
down thank you detective thank you josh
please don't discuss the case with
anyone you may have to be recalled at
some other point in time thank you
i call your next witness mr shalhorn
judge the state will next call mary
haskins gray
not sure if she's outside
all right have your detective check
mary
all right i think she's here mr
shellhorn thank you officer
to collect these uh fireworks
yes please doing anything else up on
that witness stand
hi ms gray please remain standing for a
moment please
can you place your left hand on the
bible on the witness stand please raise
your right hand please listen to my
quote
the presence of almighty god that the
testimony given to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth yes
ma'am please state your name and spell
your last name for the record mary
haskins gray and gray thank you all
right have a seat miss great thank you
please keep your voice up nice and loud
absolutely
that microphone records okay does not
amplify
okay okay
no no it's fine right there
that's just for reporting purposes but
it doesn't amplify amplify um your voice
throughout the courtroom okay
if you don't understand the question
please don't answer it just indicate you
don't understand i'll have counsel
rephrase the question so you understand
go ahead mr shellhorn good morning is
greg good morning can you please
introduce yourself to the jury
um i'm mary haskins-gray i'm a
professional defense writer and trainer
and competitor
and can you tell us a little bit about
your professional experience as a
dressage rider
in what regards
uh how long have you been riding oh
since i was five
and what is dressage
dressage i would say is like the highest
form of training we do
sort of dance moves for the horses and
patterns
it's an olympic sport
you can ride at all levels as an amateur
professional
but that's that's my main focus for the
horse is dressage
and did you also indicate you have some
experience as an instructor or a trainer
yes can you tell the jury a little bit
about that
so
i mostly train horses and riders and
then i compete also but i teach lessons
clinics
um
other
aspiring riders and a lot of times
mostly work with the horses treating the
horses
with respect to dressage is there a
difference between being a professional
and an amateur
yes can you tell the jury what that is
so professionals paid for something in
the business whether it's a boarding
business or riding lessons or paid to
ride or compete an amateur someone that
rides
without compensation without money and
what is your status professional
do you know michael garrison yes sir do
you see him in court today yes sir could
you just identify him by an article of
clothing he's wearing uh blue and red
striped high
i've identified my
gray has identified the defendant for
the record
mr barrison go ahead mr shelbourne
ms gray do you also know an individual
named lauren canada yes sir did you know
her or do you know her through your
association with mr barrison yes sir do
you know an individual named robert
goodwin yes sir and do you know him
through your same association with the
defense yes sir
can you tell the jury when it is that
you first met the defendant michael
barrasso
when i first met him i was probably a
teenager
through
competing internationally and running
the same circuit we knew of each other
through mutual friends and other
professionals
and at some point uh during your life
were you involved in a romantic
relationship yes sir and do you recall
approximately when that began
um 2015 sometime
and drawing your attention to the
uh
summer of 2019 were you still involved
in a relationship with him uh
romantically yes sir were you also
involved in a professional relationship
yes sir can you tell the jury what the
nature of that relationship was
professional yes um so i had horses in
the barn in new jersey and in florida um
we worked together
developing horses for top sport bringing
along young horses
we worked on personal goals
training our students and clients and
all of that
now you indicated that uh there were two
farms can you tell the jury specifically
where those two farms were uh one one is
in long valley new jersey and the other
in loxahatchee florida
and
what is your understanding of why the
defendant owned two farms
it's pretty common um or at least to
travel between north and south because
obviously the weather changes and to
keep
developing the horses training and
competing a lot of people will go
south for the winter and north for the
summer that's pretty common
based on your involvement with the
defendant both professionally and
romantically
are you aware of certain aspects of his
business and of his farms
yes
for example can you tell the jury of how
many horses may be boarded at the new
jersey farm at any given time
um i think towards the end we had about
40 to 45 on the new jersey farm we
didn't have that much room in florida
but that's about what we had in new
jersey and would 40 to 45 be about
capacity for what that
could board yes
did the defendant ever have employees or
students working for him yes and can you
tell the jury what a student
worker would be in the dressage
community like a working student yes
okay so that's also pretty common
working students are
people that are typically younger or
want to want to learn and
follow someone that's more accomplished
so they'll put themselves in a working
situation where they exchange work for
education so that's pretty common in the
horse industry to have younger people
come and stay
work learn progress most of them go on
to become professionals themselves and
during the time that you were working
with the defendant approximately how
many working students may be there at
any given time i'd say about four
roughly
give or take
what is a writing clinic
a clinic um
is usually where the instructor travels
to another farm or location and teaches
multiple writers per day it's usually a
lot of auditors
it's usually someone also super
accomplished teaching people that are
looking to further their education and
their riding with their horse and
that's pretty much it and does the
clinician
get paid for that yes sir
what is your understanding or experience
with
how a clinician is paid
what do you mean by check or like i
don't know what do you mean fair enough
uh
is it do they get paid a lot of money a
little amount of money or something else
i would say depending on the person and
their accomplishments it can be
typically people that have been the
olympics are usually charged pretty high
amount
are you aware of what michael verizon's
reputation was in the dressage community
yes sir
what were some of his accomplishments
that you're aware of as a writer yes um
competed internationally very
successfully
altered at the olympic games
pretty much what we all strive to
accomplish as a writer he had done it
did you ever see him coaching at any
clinics
uh yes yeah
and what was your uh experience or what
was your observations of him and the way
that he would coach and be received by
the people at the clinic he was a very
popular in love clinician
now in terms of the farm here in long
valley in new jersey where did you live
when you were here
on the farm
and can you describe for the jury a
little bit about uh what was on the
property of the farm
well there was a historical home
[Music]
there was a barn with 30 some stalls
indoor riding arena outdoor riding arena
alternate buildings with additional
stalls
a young horse area where we had young
horses that lived outside
hay fields
when you say a historical farm can you
tell the jury a little bit about the
layout uh of the farm of it's me of the
farmhouse
um well from what i understand it was a
house that was closer up to the road
that they moved further back
and actually turned into three different
living areas
did you ever live in that house i did
and at times were there other people
living in that house besides just you
yes sir
for example when you lived there did you
live in one of those
living areas with anybody
yes sir who was that michael barrison
and my children when they were here
so you have children yes sir is that uh
with the defendant or with someone else
or someone else do they live in another
place most of the year
uh mostly like when they're in school
they're mostly in north carolina i guess
and so i guess from the answer you just
gave at times they would come to the
near new jersey farm absolutely yeah and
they would stay with you at the
farmhouse yes sir
who else may have lived uh in the the
farmhouse for example when you were
living there when i was living there
lauren and rob were living upstairs
are you aware if anyone else had ever
lived in that upstairs apartment yes who
was that justin harden
now you said that there were
approximately three separate living
areas yes what was the third living area
um originally there was a basement
there's entrance to the basement where a
lot of the girls would live we had a
little kitchen and bedrooms and bathroom
down there
the main floor was a separate entrance
in residence and then upstairs had its
own entrance and that was his own
residence as well and were those
separate although they each had separate
entrances to those various living areas
were they also connected within the
inside of the building yes
now you also mentioned uh the barn and
the training areas yes can you describe
a little bit more detail about what was
in that area of the farm
inside the barn
well uh
there was a stable yes so yeah and this
table we had tack rooms we had like a
big loading dock where we kept hay a
feed room
attached to the stable was a covered
arena
and so we like a grooming area you can
go right into the ring or outside to the
outdoor arena we had a big clubhouse
with a kitchen
um an office
and you just use the word word tackroom
for those members of the jury who don't
know what attack room is what's that
it's where you keep your saddle and
bridle and
all your horse tack and then we also had
lockers where people had grooming
supplies and miscellaneous things
judge i'd like to show the witness a
number of photos
i'm going to identify those
for the record
are s290
s291
s293
s294
s295
s297
s300
and s289 judge
what have you seen those mr belinkus yes
judge no judgment
right those items will be received in
the evidence it's uh 289 290 291 293 294
295 297.
300
all in evidence go ahead i may have
neglected to say s292 i apologize all
right any objection to that mr balencas
all right s 292 is an evidence as well
and may be displayed to the jury
all right miss greg you were just uh
describing the
uh
the clubhouse at the barn uh we just
pulled up on the screen here s 289 do
you recognize that i do um have you seen
all these photos uh before coming to
court yes sir and what is s 289 a
picture of um our club room area
and does that appear to be a fair and
accurate picture of the way the club
room looked on august 7 2018.
with respect to s289
what would be at the back of the the
photo meaning if someone was standing
looking into the room what's at their
back the back left corner would be the
office
okay so looking to the to the back left
corner of this picture is the office yes
sir okay and is that where you could see
a little bit of a light next to that
what would be to the right of the office
there
inside the club
that door
is there a pool table in that room there
is yes okay and what's uh in the pool
table closer to where the picture is
taking couches
furniture and as we come closer to where
the picture's taken what's on the left
hand side the dining room table
more furniture
in your kitchen and then the kitchen and
then if someone was to turn around and
walk backwards in the direction where
the phones
wait for me to answer the question i
know you're anxious yes
let him finish
it's not it's for the jury it's also for
the record so everybody hears the
question fully
and even though oftentimes witnesses
anticipate what's going to be said just
let them finish so the jury hears it
then then you can answer all right go
ahead uh rephrase your question
so if someone was to turn around to the
direction where the photo was taken and
turn around and walk backwards what
would be behind them a door that goes
into the barn
and what as you walk through that door
what do you see when you get into that
area to the left would be
two tack rooms to the right with the
lockers would start there
now i'm going to show you s290
uh what do you recognize s290 to be a
picture of um that's the entrance from
the porch into like a fourier that went
into the cover
so would this be if uh someone was
walking into the club room from the
entrance on the parking lot yes sir
what are those
uh items that are hanging from a chain
and hook there on the
basically the middle of the picture
those are coolers or blankets from
competition um usually international
competitions and top placings
and what's so what's the significance of
what is a cooler
um i think maybe some are like
scrum sheets but they sometimes they'll
give you a cooler it's like something
you throw over the horses
cool or warm and sweating or you want to
draw them off
um a lot of times if you want a
competition they would give you a
blank blanket for the horse so some of
those might be sheets
and are you aware of what some of these
specific coolers were for that were
hanging or who had won those coolers
yes sir who would that be i would assume
most of them belong to michael garrison
and do you assume that because you've
had conversations or you knew that from
living there yeah i mean and viera had
done some things too so i don't know
like which ones exactly belong to each
person
who is vera michael's ex-wife and is
that vera kessels yes sir
do you know approximately how long the
defendant and vera kessels were married
i do not
at some point are you aware whether she
lived on that property yes sir
and she is also involved in the
equestrian and dressage
i'll next show you uh what's been marked
as s 291
what is this a picture of
this same thing on the other side so
this is the other side of that foyer
that you talked about yes and are those
also uh coolers that are hanging there
as well yes sir so is it fair to say if
someone came to the property for the
first time walks up into the building
from the parking lot this would be the
first thing they would see as they come
into the car correct
all right next i'm going to ask you what
is s 292 a picture
also the club room
and what vantage point would this be
taken from coming into the club um if
you just walked in from the porch
that would be looking to the left
are there also some coolers hanging over
there sort of in the between the windows
yes
what do those windows look at that are
on the right hand side of the picture um
the windows look out into the indoor
arena
and seating area out there where
it's set
with respect to some of the photos that
we see on the left-hand side of the the
picture and then in the middle of the
picture as well as down on the
windowsills what what are those pictures
of generally
um
big accomplishments um
great horses that were made um some some
of those on the left are of olympians
that michael coached
um his pictures with the olympic team
[Music]
some of the pictures up top are of young
horses that were purchased
and when you say great horses that were
made
what do you mean by that um horses that
were competed at the highest level um
had done
major championships or
competed internationally that were
successful and would those be horses
that were trained by michael verason or
at his farm yes sir and both like some
of the riders on the left had horses of
their own that he was involved with
stuff like that
all right next i'll uh
show you
what's been marked as s293 is this just
another picture moving further into the
center of the room
yes it is and are those pictures up on
the top above the window the pictures
you were talking about the young horses
yes sir can you tell that explain that
the significance of that again to the
jury um you mean as far as the
significance of the business or
what would what what is the significance
of the pictures what are they pictures
they were of foals that were purchased
either at auction um or through a friend
of a family member um
and that's definitely not all of the
young horses that we have but horses
that have been acquired and we had
pictures up of the holes the baby horses
and then what would the significance be
of putting those pictures up in the club
room there where people could see them
i don't think it's had any significance
other than it was meaningful to us
yeah
i guess fair to say you were proud of
what you had done
well nothing had been done with those
yet they were they were babies so that
was just
usually at auction they'll send you a
picture with a passport and so we just
displayed them
of horses for the future
and is s 294 just another picture moving
to the right
correct where does that doorway go
that door goes out into the indoor arena
and if a person wants to walk through
that door and into the indoor arena what
is right in front of them
inside a seating area and a little a
wall like a head wall to the arena
chairs
is s295 another picture of uh that room
moving towards the right
yes sir and i see a door to the right of
this picture there uh
where does that door go the door on the
far right is the door that goes out into
the barn area that was the one that you
had explained before you would go out to
where there's the tack room in the water
what was this club room used for
um
a common area we all had breakfast and
coffee and dinners and
it's just a common area for clients and
us to enjoy
uh at times was it used for entertaining
yeah for sure
um in s295 on the right there um
is that the table you were talking about
the dining room table yes yes sir
and a last question on this photo in the
back
i guess on the right side just to the
left of the
door it looks like there's some sort of
a shadow box or a frame can you tell the
jury what that is
um those it was just awards for
um those were mine actually
they were ribbons and i think
medals maybe from a championship
all right well
go on to s-296 what's that a flutter
also the club room and again is this
looking back in the direction of the
doorway out to the parking lot and the
office yes sir
and on the left-hand side of this
picture
of what's hanging on the wall in those
shadow boxes or frames more awards and
accomplishments and do you recall who's
whose those were specifically the two in
the middle were mine and the two on the
side
ss297
is obviously a picture of the kitchen
you described yes sir
now uh s 298 is this a picture from the
opposite side of the club room looking
back in the direction where we just were
yes sir
it's probably
hard to tell from the picture but can
you describe in s299 what this is uh in
the bottom of the picture
what's the piece of furniture a full
table
and last i'm going to show you s
300
do you recognize that picture
i do yeah is that just another picture
of a different area of the club room yes
sir
what if you recall were in some of those
photos that you see on the left hand
side there
um those were clients um
some of the ladies on their horses
he would have anyone that had competed
grand prix gave us a picture
and he'd been collecting those over the
years so students
clients personal horses stuff like that
and is that um there's some black and
white photos on the left there closer to
the door you know what those were photos
of i think horses from his childhood is
motherhood maybe
all right now you indicated that there's
also an office in the barn yes sir
if we were looking at s 300 where would
the office be oriented in relation to
where we are in s300 um so if i'm
standing right here looking at the
picture it would be to the right
so it looks like there's a bookcase on
the right side of the picture yes sir
would it be to the right just past there
it would
uh whose office was that
michael's and i had a desk in there as
well
all right i'm going to show you what's
been marked as s301 that i believe is
already in evidence
uh is that a picture of the office it is
and you indicated that you had a
workspace in there where was your
desktop
to the right like right when you walked
in it was to the right side so it looks
like there's a chair there on wheels yes
sir would that be the chair you're
talking about where you would sit yes
sir
and who would sit at that big desk
behind you michael would
what's s 302 a picture of the office as
well looking out
into the cover
now on the right hand side what's that
big black uh item
the safe um
not necessarily everything
um
did you have access on a regular basis
to the safe no sir
now before i move on um do you and
michael barrasson still have any sort of
a business relationship no sir
now i think you indicated that you had
met uh mr barrisone quite some time ago
and uh did you know many of the same
people in the industry we did
we do yeah
and how would you describe the
equestrian community in terms of uh
i guess size or familiarity
i think everyone's pretty familiar with
one another if you're after a certain
point yes
during the course of of time that uh you
knew the defendant worked with them and
were involved in a romantic relationship
with them did you communicate with him
on a regular basis
yes not not before we were in a
relationship yeah but when you were yes
sir and would that have been
uh through various means in person over
the phone and through text message sure
now judge may i approach yes
what's
[Music]
once again just let him finish okay
thank you and that was august 7 2019.
yes sir and you recall uh what kind of
phone it was maybe not the specific an
iphone
um judge might have permission to move
past 176 into evidence any objections on
s-176 isn't evidence yes so if you could
open that
and is that your phone that you gave to
the police yes
and you can put it back in there thank
you
and you're aware
uh or you became aware after giving that
to the police at some point in the last
uh
amount of time since the shooting uh
that that phone was processed by the
police of course yes and you understand
that they had extracted certain
absolutely yes
evidence from it yes
now during the course of time that you
and the defendant were working together
and involved in a relationship together
did you discuss various things related
to the equestrian world sure and that
would have involved
things that were going on maybe with
other people in the equestrian community
sure um did you discuss
things related to the business and
running the farm absolutely
at times um
now you indicated that the defendant was
also your coach yes sir and is it fair
to say
that based on the fact that you were
involved in a relationship with them you
were running a business with him and
that you were being coached by him
you're aware of some of his philosophies
on horsemanship and that sort of thing
can you tell the jury what horsemanship
is
i think everyone would describe that
differently um horsemanship to me would
be everything that goes into managing a
horse
everything down to the grooming the barn
the
feed the veterinary care the barrier
and then
also doing and taking as much time you
need to develop the horse in the most
correct way
what was uh the defendant's view on
horsemanship
he put a big importance on horsemanship
judge at this point if i could have a
breakout room
to show
some text messages to ms gray sure
judge for the record this is marked as
s-171
greg can you see that screen in front of
you i can
so just so you know that this item has
been marked for identification so we can
keep track of it with the record at this
point um but we won't be displaying it
up on the screen so just you'll be able
to see it so if you need us at some
point to
make it bigger okay to make it easier to
see then just tell me
and i'm gonna direct your attention to
uh line six seven seven eight of s-171
do you see that line
um
tell me the number one more time please
six seven seven eight if you look
there's a little cursor next to it and
does that indicate that it was a text
message that michael barrasson the
defendant sent you on february 17 2019
correct
and uh what did he say in that second
line of that text message
judge again
i have no objection as long as i can get
into specific conversations
right
it's quarter of we'll take our morning
break ladies and gentlemen it's right
around that time
um
we have to discuss this legal issue so
we'll take about 20 minutes so
1105 or so so use the facilities you
want to get coffee if there's coffee
around you can do that please don't
discuss the case and we'll see you about
1105 thank you
you may step down okay
hopefully resolve that legal issue over
the break call the witness back in miss
great please miss gray
all right miss gray is back on the
witness stand go ahead mr shellhorn
thank you your honor if we could just
re-pull up the breakout room please sure
and we'll resume
uh with where we we just left off
and again judge i'm referring to
exhibit for identification not evidence
s-171
ms gray we're just pulling that up in
front of you and if you recall i had
asked you
about line six seven seven eight
and i should back up um
you uh understand the exhibit i know you
don't have a physical exhibit in front
of you but it's been marked as s 171
would be your text messages between you
and michael barrisson
what are you asking me exactly
you understand that s 171 are the text
messages that were recovered from your
phone between you and michael barris
okay yes sir and you haven't reviewed
all of those before court today correct
no but you did look at some of them
before you came into court today i did
so i'm gonna direct your attention to
line six seven seven eight
is that a text message from michael
barissone to you on february 17 2019
yes sir and what was the
uh
specific text of that text message
it's in column d um
how awesome i've had the experience i've
had that experience with horses too
horsemanship is in all we do if we see
it
next i'm going to direct you to and
we're going to pull this up lines 24 17
to 24 20.
um when you were coaching excuse me when
when the defendant was coaching you
as a writer
uh was did he have certain sayings or
things that he would say at times when
he was coaching you yes
and were some of those things that he
would repeat on a regular basis for sure
and did some of them almost become
ingrained in your mind
yes yeah
and i'm directing you to line 24 17.
is that a text message from you to
michael barasone on may 18 2018
yes sir and do you ask him what are the
three things you never want to hear in
the arena yes
and then the second line where it says
he's this or he's that i'm trying and
what's the third is that you asking him
what those three things are correct and
on line 24 18
did he respond to you he did and did he
tell you what the third thing was yes
what was that i know so if i direct your
attention down to line 2420 which is two
lines down
what did he say in that text message
i don't care what he or she is or likes
if you aren't trying why are you here
and if you knew you wouldn't have this
problem
and is that consistent with something or
three things that he never wanted to
hear a writer say in the arena yes sir
judge for the record can i have the date
set forth
and the last questions that i wanted to
ask you on on this line
would be online 25
28. okay
uh and 25.29 are those two text messages
from the defendant michael barissone to
you yes sir and those are on may 23 2018
correct
and uh is the first one it's the part of
horsemanship most people don't get yes
sir
what did he say in the follow-up text
message to you
on line 2529
you want me to read it out loud yes okay
i have a limit
on that nonsense horse get a fucking
hold of yourself
you will behave you will not threaten
you will not threaten nor endanger me
and you will do what i tell you or i
will be your ass funny it's been working
perfectly a long long time
all right thank you
now in terms of how the work was split
uh at the farm on a day-to-day basis
when you were there what were your sort
of roles or responsibilities at the farm
i did a lot of the writing
not as much of the teaching but most of
the writing
had some personal clients and personal
horses
and would
ride what i needed to when i needed to
type of thing and when you say that you
were in charge of or did a lot of the
riding what does that mean can you
explain that to the training of the
horses
oh were you paid to work there no sir
did you pay the defendant anything to
board your horses there no sir
how many horses did you have living
there for example
in august of 2019 i think eight or nine
were there any other uh long-term
employees for the defendant
yes sir who was that justin hardin
and then some some kids that work for us
as working students that have been there
for a while
and can you explain to the jury who
justin hardin was and what his role at
the the barn was from your perspective
um
justin had been there a lot longer than
i had but he would be considered like an
assistant trainer he did a lot of the
teaching
to the ladies and also was a trainer of
the horses
do you know what the name of the
defendant's business was
michael bears and dressage
and are you aware whether he had a
website for that business i am yeah
with respect to the website uh
what is your recollection about what
some of the
different pages or sections of the
website were i think it showed both the
facilities
um florida and new jersey and then it
showed
picture and information on myself justin
michael
i believe these items are marked as
s73
excuse me judge s71
s72 hold on a second
71. s72
s73
s74
s75
and s76
i have no objection to these coming into
this country
all right
s71 through s76 will be admitted into
evidence
i'm going to ask you if you could first
look at
what we'll pull up here is s
71
oh
actually could i ask that you look at
first s-73
what does that 73 appear to be
maybe the home page
homepage of the website maybe
and you see a date in the top left
corner there
uh yes what's the date there august 8th
2019.
and does this appear to be a fair and
accurate i guess uh screenshot or or
print out of the way the website looked
on the update
so you said you thought that this was
the
possibly the home page
what does it say under barista dressage
i don't recall
underneath that uh what did it say in
that next line and if you need to make a
um we are a full-service world-class
dressage boarding training and coaching
business with farms in new jersey and
florida
our team of grand prix dressage riders
produces horses to international levels
and we offer limited sales
and the picture there in the middle of
the screen that would have been on the
website is what
the new jersey farm and is that the
clubhouse that you talked about earlier
correct
so if we look in the very middle of that
picture
uh you had indicated there was a like a
foyer with some coolers yes was that the
doorway that you would enter into
and where on this picture would the
office be that you
looked at pictures of
the far left window not the building on
the other side but in the front
structure the far left window
almost where that
column from the
overhang comes on
what was in the building
that is to the far left
it was a shop
workshop
scrolling down a little bit more
what is hawthorne hill
i think originally that was what john
lumber called the facility
who do you know john lombard today it
was a partner he was a partner with
michael arizona on the new jersey farm
and is it fair to say then i won't make
you read this whole thing but is this a
paragraph that was on the website that
would talk about some of the
uh facilities and what the amenities
were at the property correct
and is there also an address there
there is is that the same address as the
property that you were discussing
earlier yes sir
all right next i'm going to ask you if
you could look at s75
ns75 has that same logo
in the center as well as the same date
in the top left corner yes sir and it
has that same
i guess description of the business
right under barristone dressage
as well
yes sir
and if we scroll down on s75
who's that a picture of that's myself
just me
and
for the members of the jury who aren't
familiar with dressage
what are you wearing in that picture
i'm wearing the uniform that you compete
at fei levels so it's a
long shad bed we call it a shad belly so
long coat with tails and
competition helmet
and our white pants we ride in the shows
and then white gloves so like my
competition outfit
and if we scroll down a little bit more
and again i won't ask you i won't
embarrass you and ask you to read this
whole thing but is that uh your name as
well as a description of some of your
accomplishments and what you would offer
at the farm yes sir and your
next if i could uh direct your attention
to s76
does s76 have a date of august 7 2019 in
the top left corner it does and that's
the date of the shooting yes sir
and again has the same logo and and
language about the business in the
middle there yes sir and as we scroll
down
uh who is that a picture of michael
berezin
and again is he wearing the the common
uh attire that you would wear for an fbi
tournament yes or competition yes sir
and then does this webpage have michael
barisson's name as well as some other
information about his background and
some of his accomplishments in the
equestrian and dressage community
correct
and then the last
the last one i wanted to ask you about
at this point was s72
uh does that indicate a date of august
10 2019 it does
and if we scroll down
what is that a picture of the florida
farm
and that's the form that you indicated
that you would uh
train at when you were in florida with
the defendant correct now you indicated
that this stable was smaller than the
new jersey stable it is do you remember
approximately how many horses this
stable could accommodate um and this one
i think 14 i'm guessing as a guess
and again with this uh
with this website or this web page
rather there's the description of the
florida facilities and some of the other
amenities that are located there that's
correct
now during the summer of 2019
uh in in particular
did the defendant ever express any
concerns to you over the way that the
farm was running
yes
in general what were some of the uh
concerns he would complain of
i would say it was always like
management cleanliness
um
you know keeping things in order
i want to ask you a few follow-up
questions that that's about your own
horse ownership you indicated that in
august of 2019 you think maybe you owned
eight or nine horses
i did um can horses be expensive to buy
yes
what would be some of the factors that
may impact how expensive a horse is the
level of training uh competition
experience
talent quality age
and do people and i'll ask you
specifically about the dressage
community do people buy horses for
different reasons
for sure yes what are some of the
reasons that you bought and owned eight
or nine horses
i bought my horses
to develop
either to be competition horses or sail
horses
i'm assuming
uh that
purchasing the horse isn't where the
expenses end
absolutely not what are some of the
ownership expenses that a horse owner is
responsible for
board
training if you if you go there
feed barrier vet
competition if you compete you can go on
and on attack
riding apparel
so uh attack is riding apparel
no writing girl will be like the stuff
that you wear boots hat equipment and
then like the horse equipment and what's
tack tack is saddle bridle blankets
boots you know everything that goes on
the horse
how about you just use the term farrier
for the members of the jury who don't
know what a farrier is what's that it's
the person that trims the horse's feet
the feet grow and they trim about every
four to six weeks and they put shoes on
or leave them barefoot
during the course of time that you were
working with the defendant and involved
in a romantic relationship with him did
you ever discuss anything about his his
reputation or did you ever see him do
any things to reflect on his reputation
can you elaborate
was his reputation important to him for
sure
and why was that
i think
[Music]
all right what's the nature of the
objection
on what grounds
how does she know why his
reputation is important for the reasons
clarify that i haven't rephrased the
question
you indicated that you ran a business
with the defendant
i worked with him worked with him yes
and we just looked at a number of web
pages that uh
marketed the various properties that he
owned as well as himself and the
trainers who work there yes
did you ever make any observations of of
him and the way he would deal with
people that would indicate to you that
his reputation was important to him
i'm not sure how to answer that i think
um
in the in the horse industry your
reputation is is a lot
you know how you how you deal with
people and horses for sure
did you ever see him interact with other
people
coaching other people or training other
people besides yourself yes absolutely
and was the way that he interacted with
those people the same as how he
interacted and coached you or different
could be different and what would be an
example of it being different um
i think he was harder on me because of
our relationship and
his uh
desire to see me do well and
my his belief in my abilities so
so i guess would the corollary to that
be that sometimes he was easier on other
people that he didn't coach on a regular
basis
yes
now during the times that you interacted
with him that you were working with him
that you were in a relationship with him
did you ever know anything about the
business that he was running
yes
for example did you know anything maybe
not specifics but you did you know
general things about the finances of the
business general things and can you tell
the jury what you knew
that it took a lot of money to run a
business about
science and at times would he
indicate that to you or tell you that he
was
having issues in terms of cash flow
yes
and is it fair to say that would be with
relation to
having cash liquid available correct
do you recall approximately how
expensive it was or what the expenses
were on a monthly basis to run the farm
i would guesstimate between forty and
fifty thousand dollars a month
and i'm gonna direct your attention to
uh s 171
and i believe we i would ask for a
breakout room at this point judge
why
now you indicated that the defendant was
um
was married before you correct were you
aware of his finances related to the
divorce
not necessarily i mean i i've been
divorced so i know that finances usually
get split up
did he ever share anything with you
about
how much money he had to pay
uh out in the divorce
i'm sure yes
so first i'm going to go back i'm going
to direct your attention to line
53 98
this is again s-171
this is line 53-98 is that a text
message from michael barissone to you
in november of 2018
that says how do you think i keep all
this going 40k a month i can't go to
sleep i have to be aware every day
that is correct
and then down
approximately six or seven more lines on
line 54.05
did he send you a text message
on that same day indicating the per
month expenses at the farm
yes he did and did he indicate the lease
for the new jersey farm was six thousand
dollars a month
mortgage florida three thousand feed
five thousand dollars shavings three
thousand dollars farrier three thousand
dollars property taxes three thousand
dollars
workers eight thousand dollars insurance
three thousand dollars utilities two
thousand dollars etc etc etc
yes sir
the other text message that i wanted to
direct your attention to was online 7270
are you aware of approximately when
michael barrasson's divorce with vera
kessel's became final
i am pretty sure it was december of
2018 okay
and so this is a text message from
march 19 2019 is that correct
from michael barrasson yes
and did he say i got clipped
965k hard to feel good
yes and was it your understanding or
does that refresh your memory
that he had paid approximately that
amount of money as a result of the
divorce yes or was going to have to do
that
now you indicated that uh the
maybe this is my words not yours but
that the
dressage community is somewhat
close-knit
absolutely
are you aware of
an individual involved in the dressage
or
let's write that are you aware of an
individual involved in the equestrian
community named george morris i am and
do you know if the defendant knew judge
george morris personally i am aware of
that yes
did something happen to george morris on
august 5th 2019 yes do you know what
that was he had a lifetime safe sport
ban
and
was that uh newsworthy or noteworthy in
the questions yes
for several reasons
now you just mentioned safe sport can
you tell the jury what your
understanding of safe sport is
safe sport is for all the olympic sports
it's
something like all of us have to go
through either as a coach trainer
rider owner
it's a course you have to complete and
continuing education you have to stay up
up to date with about
all of the
basic moral values of dealing with
athletes children
everything from bullying to sexual abuse
all the things that have kind of gone on
in the past that have
brought us to this point
and um safe sport didn't exist when you
first started writing no absolutely not
so did it become something that when it
was instituted everyone knew about and
yeah yes it was a requirement to to
compete and be an active member
are you aware whether the defendant was
registered or licensed through safe
sport
i think in the beginning yes
what is the what is uscf
uh united states equestrian federation
and can you tell the jury what the role
of the united states equestrian
federation is
well we have two governing bodies we
have usdf and uscf
in order also in order to compete we
have to have
active memberships as as writer coach
owner um
they're they're governing bodies that um
we have to be members of in order to be
an active competitor
now were you aware of whether the
defendant michael barristone knew people
at the the higher levels or at the
administrative levels of the uscf i am
aware of that
at some point did the defendant ask you
to gather information about lauren
cannon
yes
and
did you have conversations with him
about contacting uscf uh in late july or
early august of 2019. yes sir
i'm going to direct your attention to s
171
line 93
38 is that a text message from michael
barissone to you on july 30th 2019.
it looks like me to michael
uh 93-38 i'm sorry
the wrong one was highlighted
um
michael to me yes
give me a reason what number is that
it's line 93 38
38
can you read that uh text message that
the defendant sent you on july 30th yes
um i need every single person who has
ever been screwed by lauren rob and the
dad barriers vets trainers every single
one
i'm going to get her a lifetime ban as a
competitor
and are the words every single person
entirely in capitals yes
did he then go on online 93 42
approximately three text messages later
to repeat every single person all in
capitals yes
did you or the defendant at some point
make a complaint directly to uscf about
lauren canreck yes do you recall when
that was
july maybe in july sometime i don't
remember it would it be fair to say it
was around the same time
that that text message was sent oh what
was when was that set
well that
you just identified that as july 30th
2009 and yes yeah
so i'm gonna
judge i'd like to ask for s 400
to be marked and entered into evidence
so i can show it to the witness and
display it to the jury
all right no objection
s4 it's 400 will be admitted into
evidence
and can be shown to the witness and to
the jurors
thank you honor
when you made the complaint to
you the united states equestrian
foundation how did you make that email
did you send the email or did someone
else
i don't remember maybe both of us
actually
did you at any point ever uh collect
materials and send them in the regular
mail or ups i did
and what specifically did you send them
um
lots and lots of information that we
gathered on lauren ganarek
and um i'm going to show you what's been
marked as s
400.
does s 400 appear to be a receipt from
the ups
store
uh dated in the top left tuesday august
6 2019 yes sir
and who is the sender
myself
who is the recipient sonya keating
what is your understanding or who do you
know sonya keating today
i think she was the main contact for
your safe sport
where did you get her name as a contact
to send this to i don't recall
did the defendant give it to you
i don't recall
all right we'll scroll down uh
to the second page of s 400 ss 400
and in the top left is that a copy of
the receipt
from the ups store yes and does that
indicate you sent it from the chester
ups store on august 6 2019 at 1 11 p.m
yes sir
scrolling down a little bit more uh it
indicates i think
correct me if i'm wrong that you bought
a box while you were there to ship the
materials in apparently yes
where it says 8.5 by 11 copies qty 756.
what does that mean to you a quantity of
756 pages
and
would that be the
does that sound approximately like the
number of pages that you would have sent
as part of this package yes you have
safe sport yes
now i think you had indicated before
that you would train at the florida farm
in the winter months and then come north
to new jersey to train during the summer
season correct approximately
approximately when did the summer season
run from
april or may to
november
ish so in august of 2019 were you here
at the new jersey farm correct
that summer when you moved here in
approximately april may where were you
living
i don't recall at the the very first
where we were living it was at the barn
in the barn apartment or we went
straight to the house i don't recall
but at some point that summer were you
living in the house absolutely yes and
is that when you referenced earlier that
you were also living in the house at the
same time as robin yes correct
you also i think indicated that justin
hardin had previously lived in the
second floor but that in the summer of
2019 robin lord were looking at that's
correct what was the reason for the the
change in living
situation
honestly i can't answer that other than
arrangements were made for her to move
in and justin to move out
well let me ask you did anything happen
to the house
are you aware of anything happening to
the house
at some point during the winter of 2018
2018
what was that there was a pipe that
burst in the top floor and the kitchen
that belonged to justin harden and the
water ran through all floors of the
house
and did you actually see some of the
damage at some point that had been done
by the water yes
what floors was that too
um
from what i understand it started in the
upstairs kitchen and then the ground
floor was
the whole kitchen area and a little bit
into the dining room was
needed a full renovation and down into
the basement as well
and the basement is where you indicated
that the working students would usually
live correct
were any of them able to live there
during the summer of 2019 no
and when you moved back into the house
in the summer of 2019 what floor of the
house were you living on the ground
floor what was the condition or state of
that floor
it was needed a full renovation
now directing your attention to lauren
canaric and rob goodwin do you recall
when you first met them approximately
approximately yes
in the winter
in florida
of 2018.
and did they then come back to new
jersey and live lauren live and train uh
in new jersey in the summer of 2018.
i don't recall i think i think that she
came as a client but i think loved maybe
elsewhere at the time
now what was the nature of your
involvement with lauren kanarek from a
business or a working perspective when
she first came to barriston dressage
um i taught her here and there
and at some point did that change
in what way
did the defendant ever ask you to do
anything uh with respect to training or
coaching or in canary
yes when was that
um i helped her even when she first came
i taught her some in florida
um
[Music]
and then mostly it was justin and then i
helped her some in the summer of 2019.
how did that go
really bad
did you express that to the defendant
yes
what was his response
um
i'm not really sure how to answer that
other than
i i wasn't able to deal with it anymore
so he was
i asked him the teacher
did you have any professional
relationship with rob goodwin
only via the horses and being around in
the barn
i mean did you ever coach him train him
with him no
what would you describe your your
personal or social relationship like
with them when they first came to the
barn
in florida
when they first came to work with
michael barrasson and barista dressage
how would you describe your personal or
social relationship with them
non-existent
so you had no interaction with them at
the beginning of their not really i mean
i told her maybe a handful of times the
first time first season in florida
but no social relationship
did you ever have a social relationship
with them i would say no
what was what was your understanding or
knowledge just what you were aware of of
the working agreement or the
professional agreement between lauren
kanreck and
the defendant
that i never really knew
did you ever have any observation did
you know why she was at the farm oh
absolutely yes what was she doing at the
farm to
work on her riding and developer horses
progress as a writer and did she come
there to work with michael barissone
with you with justin harding michael
bearson
did you ever observe them working
together yes do you know if she had any
horses at the bar she did do you know
approximately how many um the number
grew um maybe four
at one time
um are you aware if she was paying any
money to michael barassone to board the
horses train the horses or get coached
there yes
summer of 2019 whether it was at the new
jersey summer
2018. yeah
19 was at the house
and
you indicated that they were living in
the farmhouse that's correct
now we just looked at those
some of those text messages between you
and michael verizon as well as the
receipt from the ups store
is it fair to say
or or would you characterize
things between yourself and michael and
rob and lauren at that time as good or
bad
the whole environment was really bad
some time frame yes we repeat that
question
i'll re-ask you judges rephrase then all
right withdrawn and rephrase please
by july of 2019
how would you describe the relationship
between yourself and michael barrasson
with lauren canaric and rob goodman 2019
yes
the environment and the stable
and around them was really unhealthy and
toxic
at some point did michael barrasson send
you a text message telling you that he
would make things miserable for them to
say
i think that we you and i've talked
about that but i don't necessarily
recall well let me show you the text
message
and this is on s 171 judge line nine
zero eight zero
is line nine zero eight zero a text
message from michael barissone to you on
july 13 2019 yes sir
and did he text you i will just make it
so miserable to be here that they will
beg to go elsewhere watch me this i am
very very good at yes
is it fair to say that during the course
of july 2019 and august 2019 there were
conversations between you and the
defendant
about ways to get rid of lauren canorack
and rob goodman yes to get them off the
farm yes
now you mentioned that you were living
in the farmhouse with michael barrasson
and that lauren and rob were living
upstairs yes at some point that summer
do you recall if you moved out of the
farmhouse we did you remember
approximately when that was
end of july
and where did you go
up to the clubhouse
at times during
the beginning of august 2019 when you
were living up at the clubhouse at this
point
did other people come to stay at the
farm
they did you recall who some of those
people may have been my father
my son was there at some point uh ruth
cox
mary defranco
some of the kids were there the parents
type of thing
and so ruth cox for example who is ruth
cox
ruth is
a person that i owned a horse with and
michael owned a horse with i actually
had two horses with she was a partner
and a friend and a client and how
frequently would you would you say that
she would come to the box quite often
i'm going to show you what's uh
line 9350
on s171
and if you is that uh a text message
from michael barissone to you on august
3rd 2019. yes
did he tell you i need people here
adults granddad i told ruth she can't
leave they will be broken by force of
numbers that is correct
and that was after you had moved out of
the farmhouse and up to the clubhouse
that's correct
and i forget i think
you had said that it was very the things
up there were very toxic or something to
that effect
that's an understatement
now were you aware in the beginning of
august 2019
so after you move out of the
farmhouse on about july 30th you're
living in the clubhouse
for those first couple of days in august
of 2019 are you aware of whether anyone
explicitly told lauren and rob to leave
the problem
at some point yes it was said through um
i think i actually said it at one point
it was set through an attorney in a
meeting
so yes
are you aware of whether michael barason
ever told him to leave
i'm not aware of that
i'm going to direct your attention to
line 9 3 6 4
and nine three six five okay is 9364
a text message from you to michael
barrasson on august 3rd 2019 yes
and did you ask him why can we not say
to lauren and rob and the father because
still no one actually has we are
evicting you you must leave no one has
said it that's correct and is his
response to you online 9365
monday morning yes that's correct
moving down several more lines to line
93-71
is that another text message from later
that day on august 3rd 2019 yes is that
a text message sent from michael
barrisson to you at 7 11 pm
yes and does he say
let the calm stay give the man
are you
in meeting with her in that room uh was
the door open or closed closed was
anyone else in that room
when you were having substantive
conversations with her about why she was
there yeah
did anyone ever interrupt you yes who is
that michael garrison do you recall how
many times he interrupted you
three maybe
and without getting into specifically
what the caseworker may have said
after she told him something what did he
do
would he stay in the room oh he would
leave
at some point did he come back into the
room and ask you to leave the room
yes
where did you go after you left the room
we went to the room adjacent to the
office
and did that have a door on it it did
were you able to see
where michael barrisson went or what he
did after he asked you to leave the
office no
what were your observations of his
demeanor at the time that the caseworker
arrived
terrified
horrified um
and panic um
despondent i mean just completely
obsessed
did you see him um at that point running
around the clubhouse or the barn at all
no did he raise his voice or yell or
scream or anything at that point no not
that i'm more of
now at some point did you become aware
that there were police at 411 west mill
road on august 7th
yes do you recall how you became aware
of that
um
i think i'd come out of the office and
my father was actually walking up the
driveway
so he told me
do you have any personal knowledge of
what happened at the
farmhouse that after
so
this great
you indicated that your status is
professional correct correct
what is lauren cataract's
addiction
as far as i know adult amateur
and
what is the quality of her riding
ability
what's the basis for the objection i
think there could be a foundation
there could be a foundation laid but i
don't think there's any foundation for
that question to be asked
i think it also calls for opinion but
depending on the
nature of the foundation she's the
trainer
over an extended period of time
i don't know
i'll agree with your characterization
over an extended period of time
but she did indicate that um
at points um
she worked with
um
miss canorack
prior to the defendant so
i i don't find a question objectionable
i'm not sure of the relevance but
i'll allow council some wheat uh leeway
in that regard
what's lauren canorex riding ability
she actually has quite a bit of ability
and and
capability to be a great rider
but she rides as an amateur if that's
what you're asking
and
do you consider yourself a better writer
more accomplished writer than she
i wouldn't say a better writer it's you
don't even really have to have talent if
you want to put the time in and work on
getting better i have
competed more and have more like
accolades because i've been doing it a
long time but
the average person can learn to ride if
they want to put the time and effort in
right
did lord cataract put the time in based
on your observations occur not
necessarily
did she always show up
when she was scheduled to ride most of
the time not
did she cause disruption within the
staple for the dressage business
while she was there
a lot of times yes
so
the prosecutor asked you specific
questions about the farmhouse the three
different living areas
directing your attention to july of 2019
that was after there was a flood correct
correct
and
where was michael barrasson when that
flood occurred
in florida
with you
yes
was anyone living in the house at that
time to your knowledge not to my
knowledge now
in the
summer of 2019
was the house under construction
yes
where you and michael
were living
on the main floor of that
farmhouse
was that
partially
being
renovated
it was
i don't think it had started yet but it
was
gutted and empty
it was gutted there was no insulation
could you hear the tenants
above you yes
lauren and robert goodman correct
correct
and
did there become a problem
with them living above you
yes
what was the problem
um
we're made to
is that because
you think he believed that you had the
talent to accomplish great things in
your sport i do
and
would you agree with me that
he didn't push lauren cataract
as hard as you correct
absolutely not
did he believe that she did not have the
talent or the drive objection to do that
yeah um
i think that's objectionable about what
was in mr barrison so
question will be stricken move on
now
you indicated on directive that michael
barrasson's reputation
means a lot to him correct
correct
does your reputation mean a lot to you
sure
and was your reputation attacked by
lauren cataract and robert goodwin
yes
did they basically do the same thing
to you
that they were doing to michael barrasso
hold on a sec
let me see that sidebar
now
you indicated that michael barrisson's
reputation is important to him correct
correct
do you know any
other
professional athlete or
dressage
trainer whose reputation is not
important to them
no sir
now
do you have personal information with
regards to lauren cataract
attacking
michael varus's reputation yes
and again
the prosecutor brought out that you
you sent
750 some pages
to safe sport
with respect to a complaint
that you made against lauren cameron
correct
correct
what was in those
750 pages that the prosecutor
brought out indicated i mean generally
speaking
generally speaking
all of the horrible things that she had
said about us
and had said to other
people horrible threats and
abuse on social media
and you
specifically said the actual post with
her words to them correct correct
you said social media posts with regards
to
threats that were made against you and
michael barrasso correct correct
and michael barrisson saw these
threats on social media correct correct
how do you know that
we would look at them together okay
next question and could you tell me
what effect what impact
did those social media posts have on
michael
barrison
um
we both we were terrified
of what it was building to and what was
coming next he was he was absolutely
petrified and terrified
and
did you or he do anything
with regards to hiring certain people to
try to protect yourself
we did
is in the fact that
a private security guard was hired to
sit
at the top of the hill in front of the
stables
to guard the stables and the people
inside that's correct
were you concerned about just your
or your staff's personal safety or the
safety of the horses in the stable
um
both
um
did any of the
clients
take precautions with regards to
protecting their horses
based on these social media posts yes
sir
what did they do
slept in front of the horse's stalls and
some of the ladies were super concerned
about
the status and the barn
and what was the threats being made
it's your testimony that
grown
women would actually sleep
in front of the horse stables
correct because they were concerned for
their own horse's safety correct and can
you tell me what effect did you observe
that had on michael barriston
i mean everything just was materializing
more and more every day
that she was doing and
he was absolutely unraveling
now
was a private investigator hired to do a
complete background check
on lauren cataract and robert goodwin
correct
is that one of the things that you sent
to safe sport
uh yes i think so yes
and
i'm not asking you what was in that
can you tell me what impact that had on
michael barrisson when he got that
background check on both of those people
we were horrified these people were
living on our property
and we're unaware of these things were
you afraid of them i was yes was michael
barisson terrified of them yes sir
now let's talk about his business for a
second
takes a lot of money to run a course
statement correct
correct prosecutor
showed you some breakdown that michael
had sent you correct correct
did michael
usually always make his payments
and keep things afloat always
and was was it a struggle at times like
it is for everyone else all right mr
blinkist
everyone else isn't on trial here so
keep your questions and comments to the
issues in this case please
you indicated that michael barrasso
always paid his bills correct correct
irrespective of a cash flow problem
you're also aware of the fact because
you're familiar with his business
and his personal finances that he had
millions of dollars worth of assets
correct correct
he owns the farm in florida free and
clear correct correct
he owns a number of horses which could
be worth close to a million dollars
correct correct
and he has some investment accounts
correct correct
and even though
at times
it was a struggle to keep all the bills
paid
at some point in time
he told lauren cataract objection
we discussed this at the break your
honor
i'm sorry to leave your property well
hold on a second hold on a second
let me see you at sidebar
now the prosecutor uh
asked you questions with regards to a
text like no one officially
told lauren cataract
to leave remember that text
yes sir isn't it a fact that numerous
people
had told cataract
it's time to leave judge what again mr
blancas
i just ruled on that
just i thought i was referring to
response to that text
judge i'll move on if you get look the
text message was read if you want to
refer to the text message that's fine
but
i ruled it it's improper to go outside
of what this witness testified to in the
text message
with regards to that text it says that
no one officially told her to leave
correct correct
isn't it a fact that unofficially
numerous people told
her to leave
you know what ladies and gentlemen let's
take our lunch break now and i'll
resolve this legal issue once and for
all all right please don't talk about
the case we'll resume at um
try to get back at around 120 so
everyone's assembled we can start at 1
30. all right thank you all please don't
discuss the case
purpose of that text message was not to
show whether or not lauren canara had
actually been asked to leave the
property or not it obviously goes to the
defendant was not looking to get rid of
her because he was not in fear he did
not have a reasonable belief that he had
to act in self-defense so that text
message goes to show his state of mind
it is not offered i recognize it came in
that way but it's not offered to show
whether or not she was actually told
because her state of mind whether she
was actually told or not
has no relevance really or bearing on
his guilt or not guilt
judges that's not the impression that
was created with that text that i
objected to
the the sense says official the jury has
the impression that up until right
before the shooting no one ever told
counteract to leave and that's a
conversation they had with my client and
i can't put my client on
you can
you choose not to that's that's up to
you so don't say you can't put them on
you can't letting that text then judge
it creates a prejudicial impression that
barizone basically was sitting on his
hands which again falls into the line of
what the prosecutor was saying that he
wasn't afraid
and she was told by different people
you know that barista i know but but but
here's the thing
her state of mind
counteracts state of mind whether that's
not really an issue it's it's mr
barrett's own state of mind
i'm talking about mary haskins gray
judge when she if you want to ask her if
she asks miss counteract to leave you
can do that that's her testimony she did
it
she can tell you about it when it
happened where it happened what the
reaction was but can she also explain
judge that that word with regards to a
fish official that she was aware that
other people no
all right
because how does she how does she get
that information from other people
it doesn't matter it's still hearsay
if you want to call other people in to
testify about it then call other people
you can't bring out your whole case
through one witness and say well it's
other people it's inappropriate you
can't cross-examine that
you want to bring in a meeting that she
wasn't even attending that's complete
hearsay
i'm not gonna allow it
i can ask this witness if she did and
when she did it in the circumstances
that much all out
but not other people
be back at
120 so we can start at 130.
how sophisticated were they
right
that's fair for some of them yeah
definitely some a lot of them were
uh
is gray out there
miss gray
she was when i just came back in judge
i do not see her she might be around
them
i think she may have moved when they
were bringing the defendant and they
cleared the hallway yes
this
yeah
um
journey entering
hmm
[Music]
all right good afternoon members of the
jury please be seated
i will call miss gray to the stand
resume
her testimony
hi miss gray
have a seat we're going to resume your
testimony now
all right go ahead mr valentine's
miss gray i'm
referring to the post that you uh
testified to
direct that in response to the
prosecutor's question
with regards to warren cataract
officially being told to leave
did you personally
at any point
tell her to leave prior to that text
message i do believe that at some point
i said if you're so unhappy then why
don't you leave yes
okay and you know
approximately when in time that was made
i don't recall
no
um prior to that text
um
were you involved personally
with michael in contacting an attorney
to start legal proceedings to get them
out yes sir and what's the name of that
attorney uh stephen tarshis and
did there come a period of time
approximately a month
where the father was in europe
uh and everything was stalled yes sir
who is the person
making all the decisions based on your
interactions with regards to lauren
cataract and her staying on the form
michael and the father is that what
you're asking me
yes when you say the father lauren's
mother what did lauren's father do
as far as
this situation
strikeout i'll withdraw the question
was it
lauren's father who negotiated
everything with michael to your
knowledge
let's just how did do you know that fact
were you present during the negotiations
no
okay
um
with regards to those uh
postings that
you you talked about
on cross
um
did you ever see michael barrasson break
down
in response to what he saw on those
social media posts yes sir and can you
describe some of those instances to the
jury
um
he continued to
become more and more fearful
to unravel to be in panic sheer panic
to say we were concerned or worried was
is an understatement um but as things
escalated day by day
his
deterioration
increased
did he ever break down
and literally get into a fetal position
yes sir
you witnessed that yes sir
now
you were asked about a number of
pictures
at the stable area
after you fled the farmhouse with
michael and your child
you were living in that club room that
was depicted correct correct
and
and
that's a pretty
straight thing
that whole room
is surrounded by more ceilings
walls
yes the office is surrounded by
uh the same thing
wood
yes sir big heavy doors wooden doors
correct yes sir now did there come a
time when
you
believe that your private conversations
were being reported yes sir and when was
that
um i would say
when we had moved up there um so the end
of july going into august was when we
determined that was happening and
how did you make that determination
um
lauren would text
and taunt michael over things that only
we had discussed
in private
things you discussed
in private in the club room club room
and office
the office where the safe is
yes sir
and
when lauren would post something on
social media
did she always keep it up or would she
delete it
a lot of times it would be deleted
some things were left up yes okay but
other things were in fact deleted
correct correct
and at times did you take or try to take
screenshots of those things
to document the exact words that were
being said yes sir
now
were you presents
on the four occasions that michael
barriston called 9-1-1
yes sir
on august 31st
when the police arrived
did you
personally hear him say objection
no mr malinkas
sustained
you were you were present for each time
he called 9-1-1 correct correct
and
i'm not asking you what was said but he
had a conversation
with the police on each occasion correct
absolutely yes did you personally see
him try to show them some of these posts
or
screenshots yes i did
and what was their reaction
they did not take it seriously
and
what effect if any did you observe
those interactions
have on michael barrasson
it made it all a lot worse
did it make it worse for you
yes absolutely
now
the prosecutor talked to you about uh
the type of person michael barrison was
with regards to his business
uh specifically that uh
you know how he ran his business
you indicated and again correct me if
i'm wrong that you express concerns
with regards to how michael barristone
was
conducting his day-to-day business
operations correct i did yeah
was
michael barissone
in a
fragile state of mind running the
business at that time mr balinkas
let me see outside more please for a
minute
is great yes first of all before i ask
you the next question
you said that michael's barista was in a
in a fetal position position did that
happen more than once
yes
how many times
it could be quite often
and was he depressed
yes sir
was he severely anxious
very much
at any point in time when you
saw him going through all of this did he
ever come angry
no
have you ever seen any violence
displayed by michael barrisson at any
point in your relationship with him no
sir no violence
yells a lot sometimes correct correct
now
did those things those specific things
that you just described with regards to
his
reaction to these events
affect his ability
to run his
business yes very much
affected his ability to make decisions
at times
yeah that's that's mr bulenkos
i'm not sure she's if you want to get
into specifics about it but
you know you're asking her to
opine on the defendant's state of mind
in that question so
the objections sustained
now
the prosecutor asked you questions with
regards to michael's divorce from his
wife
vera um
and showed you a specific text message
to your knowledge
does michael have a good relationship
with his ex-wife
yes sir
so when he talked about having to her to
pay
having to pay her 900 000 plus in that
text
do you believe he held any animosity
towards her based on that judge can we
be heard at cyborg i i apologize because
i know the jury is here but
i had questions being withdrawn by mr
balancas
[Music]
the prosecutor asked you questions about
george morris and the
safe sports band do you recall those i
do
now
did lauren cataract
file a complaint against you
yes sir
and how did that turn up
objection
what's the basis for the objection i
don't know what the relevance to the
outcome of any of cities and what is
the testimony of mr morris
well i don't see it relevant
what the outcome of it was
or the nature of it
now
there's been testimony on direct
that you sent safe sport hundreds and
hundreds of pages correct
that's correct
did you have any uh
contact with them by way of email
at what time
at any point in time prior to the
incident
i did
yeah
um
to your knowledge in your presence did
michael have any contact with say sport
by email
well not safe sport directly for either
of us we were talking to uh sonia keane
on email okay
and again did you sometimes draft the
emails for michael sometimes yes
i'm going to show you defense exhibit
1000b
and refer you specifically to number
274.
yes
[Music]
yes
it's great i'm going to show you d
d1000b
and refer you to a specific email
on
august 3rd
27th
number 274 and ask you to read this
whole thing
okay to herself yes
no to yourself
okay
do you recall uh helping michael draft
that email
i do
judge i'd like to
introduce that and read that email at
this time
i would object
you have a copy that the court can see
come up come up the side more
[Music]
and thank you
you indicated on direct examination that
in july
of 2019
that the relationship with lauren
tataract was toxic unhealthy
did you
ever discuss personally with michael
barrasson
having cataract removed from the
property yes sir
and
you've already talked about
getting a lawyer involved correct
correct
prior to august
was lauren cataract's father in europe
yes sir
to your knowledge was he contacted
with regards to by who
again this with knowledge that's could
be based on hearsay if she contacted him
that's one thing
she's got to have a basis for her
knowledge were you there when anyone
personally contacted the father yes sir
who contacted the father michael bearson
did he send the objection judge
i didn't even hear the quest i didn't
hear the question yet so i can't rule on
it so let mr blinkist finish the
question and then i'll rule on it
what's your question
did
were any
of these postings sent to the father to
your personal knowledge
yes
now
you indicated that your father
came up
in the beginning of august correct
correct
who asked him to come up
i think both michael and myself did
and why did you wish your father
because i was terrified
did anyone else come up
to the state stable when things started
to get
toxic
yes sir who
uh dr ruth
and cox you say dr ruth
cox
is she a uh
psychologist yes sick
and and that's the woman you said was
sleeping in front of her
horses stall
yes sir
now
after you started living in the
clubhouse with michael barrasso
did things get worse
as far as
the social media
attacks a lot worse yes
and
is it in the fact
that lauren cataract
would
come up late at night
with a flashlight to taunt you
and the people in the stable area
i'm going to object to the continued use
of the word taunting and threatening
obviously
yeah i mean that's the witness hasn't
testified about that you can ask her
what she observed
herself from her own personal knowledge
but don't characterize it
did you observe lauren cataract
coming from the farmhouse area
up towards the stable area in the woods
turning your flashlight on and off
i think that was michael that saw that
all right we'll strike that answer then
if it's not the witness's answer she has
no personal knowledge of it it's hearsay
if it was told to her so members of the
jury please strike from your memory that
last answer you can't use it for any
purpose
miss great
with regards to the social media posts
did lauren canorack use any of your
private
conversations with michael barrasso
and post them
on social media
yes sir
you were ask specific questions with
regards to your son and his relationship
with michael barry
is michael barrasson
ever alone with your son you not being
there
that's my knowledge maybe in passing or
but we were always together
yeah
did michael barrasson love your son very
much objection mr blinkist
this witness can't testify about the
defendant's state of mind
can you ask her about her relationship
but not
embarrassing mr barrisson's feelings
about other people that's not proper
sustained directing your attention to
august 7th
now
dcpp
comes to the farm correct for stable
area correct okay um you have a meeting
with her in michael barrasso's office
correct correct
and there
she told you that there was an
allegation objection
it's what
what's that what's the basis of it she
can't testify to what somebody else told
her
mr balinkas don't make comments come on
dcpp correct correct
michael barrasson
continually opened the door
and came in the office while you were
talking correct correct
did dcpp
tell you who made the allegations
just answer yes or no no
did did she give you
any indication who may have
done it's the same question it's
different judge she didn't give it he
didn't give a name but an indication
you're just asking the same question a
different way
did she say anything with regards to who
made the allegation
she said it
that's hold on
this is hearsay
just answer yes or no
did the dcp
workers specifically tell you who made
the allegation just answer yesterday
and as you sit here
today
are you afraid of lauren counteract
objection that's sustained
did robert goodwin
ever threaten you
yes sir
did an incident happen on august 8th
objection
yeah yes how long ago state
it's after that's
between mr goodwin and the witness
yes
and your father
what's the
what's the relevance of that
when
you believe that
your private recordings were
the private conversations were being
recorded
did
you or michael do anything with your
knowledge
to try to address that and
address that situation and determine
what was going on yes sir what did you
do
um we hired
like a
private investigator type person that
did debugging
to come to the farm and go through our
office club room locker area to look for
recording devices
and
that's great
yes um this is great you were asked
about uh dr cox coming to visit the farm
in those days of august 2019. yes sir
had she ever
wanted to sleep in the barn near the
horses before no
she had never been warned not to sleep
in the barn because it reflected poorly
on the business
i like wait i mean i don't think she
slept in the bar now
prior to this
judge if i could uh have a sidebar
i'm gonna show the witness
you need a breakout room
i'm sorry a breakout room yes breakout
room
and i'm gonna
show her s-171
peace
and i'm going to direct your attention
to line 5735
is that a text message from michael
barissone
to you on december 7th 2018
that's correct
and does that refresh your memory that
the defendant told you ruth gave me a
never-ending text about how she needs to
be near dd and how could i be so cruel
to not let her sleep in the barn that is
what that says yes
if i could also have permission to show
the witness what's been marked as s-172
sure in the breakout room
yes
and i'm going to direct your attention
to line two zero four three
is that a text message between you and
ruth cox on december 4th 2018
yes
and is that your refresh your memory as
to whether or not the defendant had
advised dr cox no more sleeping on the
couch or floor in the club room
because it's an olympic facility not a
trailer park that's correct i object to
that it has nothing to do with the
stable area judge the implication was
that dr cox was sleeping in the bar
because she was so frightened and
terrified and this clearly goes to show
that she had done that or wanted to do
that on prior occasions this has to do
with the club as
all right i get it i get it
i sustain the objection
move on mr schneiderlin you were asked a
number of questions about uh mr
garrison's
demeanor i guess
in july and august of 2019
yes
and i think you were asked a series of
questions by mr bolinkis
whether he was depressed
seriously severely anxious
uh do you remember that line of
questioning
today yes um
would you say or would you agree
that the defendant had issues with
depression or anxiety before lauren
kanrak ever came to the farm
yes
and at times would he make statements to
you
indicating
the extent of that anxiety or depression
yes and that was before he even met her
correct no further question chuck
did the interaction
and what was going on with lauren
cataract exasperate those conditions
very much
were you afraid
based on
that decline
that michael barrasson was going to kill
himself
yes that crossed my mind for sure
as
late as when in relationship to the
shooting
the day before
nothing
oh you may step down
okay yes thank you all finished ms gray
thank you
all right mr shalhon call your next
witness
we'll call justin harden
justin justin harden
please remain standing for a minute
place your left hand on that bible mr
horton if you would please raise your
right hand and listen to my court clerk
administer an oath do you swear in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony gives to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth i do
please state your name and spell your
last name for the record justin hardin
h-a-r-d-i-n thank you all right have a
seat mr harden please keep your voice up
nice and loud we have jurors in the
first two rows in the gallery if you
don't understand a question please don't
answer it just indicate you're not sure
or you don't understand and i'll have
counsel rephrase
go ahead mr shellhorn thank you honor mr
hardin can you please introduce yourself
to the jury
justin hardin and how old are you 42
do you know michael verasan i do do you
see him here in court today i do would
you identify him by an article of
clothing as well uh blue and red tie
by identifying a defendant
where do you currently live in jargon in
wellington florida
can you tell the jury a little bit about
your
own professional experience and what you
do for a living
i am a horse trainer and competitor
and is there a specific discipline that
you currently train and compete in yes
what is that dressage can you tell the
jury in your own words basically what
dressage
um
dancing with horses
have you ever ridden any other
equestrian disciplines i have can you
tell the jury what those are or what
those were
western and uh
eventing and approximately how long have
you been
training and competing in dressage
approximately 22 years
now i'd like to draw your attention back
mr mr schoenhorn something has come up i
need to address
so i know it's early in the afternoon
but i do have to address it my staff
just informed me so i'm just going to
take a quick five minute break
i said i was gonna be quick
mr horton just step outside for one
moment
i need to see council at uh sidebar when
mr velinkus
gets back
he's honestly
all right mr horn you may have a seat uh
go ahead mr shellhorn
thank you judge
i apologize if i already asked you this
question but i think i was halfway
through it
but could you tell the jury
approximately when you first met the
defendant
in 2002 can you tell the jury how you
first met him
i was applying for a job at his farm
do you recall which farm that was
his farm in new jersey
what was the job that you were applying
for at that time
a intern would say working student
what does that term generally mean to
you
it's a
um
it's an opportunity to learn more about
the horse business and gain experience
did you get that job i did
from approximately the time you got that
job in 2002 until
2019
did you continue a professional
relationship with the defender yes
did your role or job change with respect
to the farm or working with him yes how
did it change
it evolved over time
in the summer of 2019 what was your
position
assistant trainer
now working uh
working there from approximately 2002 to
2019
did your
business relationship with the defendant
at some time become more of a friendship
yes
are you familiar with whether or not he
owns any other farms yes and can you
tell the jury where that other farm or
those other farms are
in loxahatchee florida
did you have an opportunity to work at
both of those farms during the course of
time you were associated with the
defendant yes
can you tell the jury the reason why the
defendant owned two farms
the winter season is a
important competition time for our sport
as well as the weather
and would it be fair to say that the
winter competition is down south
yes
now i'm going to ask you a few questions
about the nature of michael barissone's
businesses for example was it common for
him to board more than one horse at a
time yes
do you recall with respect to the new
jersey farm approximately how many
horses there were stalls or living
quarters for
for stalls there was 33
as well as
a
area for young horses
and was it common for those uh stalls to
be more or less filled with horses yes
now you indicated that when you
initially came to work for the defendant
you were working as a working student
yes was it common for him to have
working students
associated with the farm during the time
you were there yes
what was the approximate number of
working students that may be working at
any given time
it would vary but i would say between
four and eight
are working students paid
generally no
what was their uh i guess compensation
or what did they receive as a result of
working at michael garrison's farm uh
living quarters
uh and
opportunity to learn
with about the horses
can you tell the jury what a writing
clinic is
a riding clinic is
usually a two or three day period of
time where
a clinician or teacher will
teach
basically for the whole day a series of
of riders and horses
generally the clinician would be from
out of town traveling
have you ever
been a clinician at a writing clinic i
have are you aware of whether michael
barrasson has ever been information yes
he was would you say that he did that
with any frequency during the time that
you worked for him very much so
you had also indicated that you are a
competitor yes can you tell the jury a
little bit about what a horse
competition entails
our sport has a set time for your
competition and a predetermined routine
that you are judged on
so you you get the routine in advance
yes and then do you practice that
specific routine with your horse yes
are those events held at the farm or
barn where you're training or somewhere
else somewhere else how do the horses
and the riders get to
the
location where the event is
um
owners either have their own their own
transportation
or they will have them shipped there
commercially
did the defendant or was the defendant
ever involved with transporting horses
uh
for horses that were training at his
farm to various events yes and would
that be something that the owner would
pay extra for or would it be included in
the price of boarding and training in
general trailering was extra
now with respect to the new jersey farm
at any time when you were working there
where did you live
on the farm
and i'm gonna show you uh judge if i
could
pull up s
391
which is already in evidence
sure
and mr hardin that's uh what's been
marked in evidence as s 391 what do you
recognize that to be
that would be the new jersey farm
and can you indicate for the jury on
this uh map
the approximate area where the
farm house is located that you indicated
you lived in
um
oh yeah i'm sorry
they won't be able to see where you're
pointing um there should be a pointer
next to you and we can try that
we'll see if it works it might not work
with this
i don't think so
okay
well can you describe the area the jury
has already seen this so i think they'll
know where you're talking about okay
near the top left of the picture
um
there is visible the roof of a farmhouse
and can you describe that farmhouse uh
how many levels is it
two levels and a basement
did you live on various uh locations or
in various levels of that farmhouse over
time yes where did you live when you
began living there in the basement did
anyone else live in the basement yes who
else lived in the basement other uh
assistants working there at the time
and what was the general layout of the
basement at that time
uh several bedrooms and a common living
area
over time as your roles and your role
and responsibilities at the farm changed
did you move to another location in the
farmhouse i did where was that on the
top floor of the farmhouse
and what was the general layout or set
up there
it was a two-bedroom
apartment with the living room in the
kitchen
do you recall approximately
for how long you lived in that apartment
until
the spring of 2019.
do you recall when you may have moved up
there initially
approximately 2004
so you have lived there for
a number of years yes
now with respect to s 391 uh is it fair
to say that the
that's the driveway going down the
middle of the the
diagram next to the farmhouse yes and in
the bottom right hand corner
can you describe and if it's easier for
you i'm sure the judge would allow you
to come down and point it out for the
jury if you could just describe
what some of those facilities are in
that bottom right hand corner
uh it's the main stables
where the horses were kept
and the indoor and outdoor riding arena
also on the very bottom right are the
paddocks and the round pen
and what's the
significance of the paddocks and the
round bed that's where the horses would
spend their time outside some of the
there's others some of the
when they would spend their time outside
and the round pen was used for training
um young horses
are the various fields and all maybe
i'll just start with it looks like there
are two green fields that are on both
sides of the driveway
and then there's a third green field
sort of on the right hand side of the
diagram there were those part of the
property yes
and what was
was there anything done with those kids
they were used for farming hay for the
horses
is the driveway that goes down the
center of s 391
flat
no
and do you can you describe that for the
jury
uh
from the street the first part of the
driveway is a pretty consistent incline
and then flattens out
about a third of the way
so based on your familiarity with living
there for
15 years or so
if you were at the
stable facility in the bottom right
corner are you able to see
the farmhouse from there
no
are you able to see any part of the
farmhouse to know from an orientation
standpoint where it is the very top of
the roof
and then the
i guess at the other side if you were at
the farmhouse are you able to see from
the farmhouse to where the stables and
barn are no
now you indicated that there were
there's a stable and there's also an
indoor arena as part of that big
building there yes what else was was
part of that big building well what else
was in there
uh there was a clubhouse with a kitchen
and a common area
and also a workshop
what was the general
decor in the uh the clubhouse there
farm
country
were there anything
or was there anything hanging on the
walls or displayed
with respect to some of the
accomplishments of other either michael
barrissone or people that he had trained
yes
judge i'd like to show
the witness a number of pictures at this
point
one of these newer these and evidence
these are new photos of your honor
s318
three
326 327
328
329
330.
all right mr blinkist you've seen those
photos yes there's no adjustment to them
all right those uh photographs i think
it's 318 through 330 will be admitted
into evidence
they'd be displayed to the witness and
the jury
mr hardin the first uh photo that we
pulled up here is s-318
what is that a photo
uh that would be the
center of the main stables
now i think you indicated one end of the
stable when we were just looking at the
aerial shot was connected to the end
with the club room and the indoor arena
yes what was that the other far end of
the stable
oh were there doors or anything else
there were doors on all ends of the
stable
so there was doors on all ends
and
this door that we're looking at a
picture of an s318 where is this door
would have been a side door
approximately halfway down the structure
and if you were to go out that side door
in s-318 where would that bring you onto
the front
on to the outdoor arena
i'm going to
go to s3 19
what is s319 a picture of
this would be the far end of the stables
farthest away from the indoor riding
arena
and from the location where this picture
is taken
what would be on the stables to the
outside to the left
the parking lot and what would be on the
outside of the stables to the right the
outdoor arena
and is this the
area where you indicated that you
thought there were stalls for
approximately 33 horses 25 25
thank you
s
320
is s3 what's s320 a picture of
this would be the other side of the
first picture that we saw
so this would be
a
hallway looking out into the driveway
now that um entryway just after the
the hallway out to the outside what's
inside there a wash doll for washing the
horses
and is this the opposite side
yes
that's s321 just for the record we'll
move on to s3
22.
is it fair to say that generally these
photos are coming
down the isle of stalls closer to the
club room yes
and is the doorway that you see on the
left there the wash stall you just
mentioned yes
all right i'm going to draw your
attention now to s323
is this also a picture in that same
hallway with all the stalls yes
and what is uh what is this a picture
uh that would be a picture of the doors
of the two tack rooms
those are the two white doors on the
left
yes
and where does that hallway go to uh
into the club room
straight ahead
it looks like the
aisle sort of turns off to the left
there
yes where does that go
into the indoor riding arena
on basically the center of this photo uh
what are those wooden objects in the
center this would be uh cubbies
and what are those used for uh clients
could store their personal items in
there
what are the big black um
metal objects in the middle of the
picture uh
window grates for the stalls of the
horses
now i'm showing you s324
it looks like we can see those
stalls uh the stall doors that you just
talked out talked about in the bottom
right
and you just have to answer yes yes no
turn to the record thank you
um
on the left are those more of those uh
lockers or cubbies that you discussed
yes
and those would be used by
clients
what is that white door straight ahead
where does that go
that would be the door leading to the
club room
how about the stairs on the right hand
side there
uh those leading that's leading to the
upstairs above the club room what was on
the upstairs part of the club room uh
storage mostly
okay
all right this is
s325
uh this is a closer up picture of the
door into the club room
and i'm sorry yes sorry yes that's all
right
uh
what are those pictures of on the right
hanging there
horses in competition
and are you familiar with who the riders
are in those three photos yes who are
they
uh michael
mary hoskins and myself
and are you the person that got cut off
on the top i am
nice course
uh
right then we're looking at s 326
uh
i believe this door was closed in a
prior picture yes that um
what is inside of that room
it's the saddles and bridles for the
horses
and what's that room called attack room
and is s327 a photo inside of a tack
room yes
that's s328 is that just the other side
of the same tack room yes
what is s329 a picture of
um it's the outside of the attack room
and what are all of these objects that
are hanging on the wall here next to the
attacker
um
they're um
they
signify participation in uh
international horse competitions
and do you
do you know who had earned every single
one of those
i won't put you on the spot to ask
i don't think i could say for certain
every single one
did you have any uh of those up there
yes and did the defendant michael
verizon yes uh did mary haskins
yes
and uh is it fair to say that there were
others for people who had trained at the
farm or been coached by michael yes
and this just for the sake of
completeness is s-330
a picture of that other door on the
other side of those awards yes
all right thank you mr hart
now with respect to uh the the club room
was there an office on the opposite side
of the club room yes whose office was
that
michaels
is it fair to say that after being at
the property for the amount of time that
you were
you had been in that office before
i had
and were you aware that there was a safe
in that office
yes who had primary access or control of
that safe michael
were you aware of the combination to the
safe certain times i was
and then directing your attention
specifically to august of 2019
do you recall being in the safe at all
during that time period i do not
are you aware aware of whether or not uh
michael barazone had any firearms on the
property
i was can you tell the jury what your
understanding or knowledge of that was
uh there was a
firearm in the safe
do you recall what type of a firearm
it was a
somewhat long
small
gun
was it a handgun when you say a long
small gun was it a handgun or a rifle a
two-handed shotgun i suppose okay so
like a longer gun yeah
a shorter version of a longer gun got it
go ahead mr shelton
this is actually i'm going to move into
another topic here so i can keep going
or if you want to take the afternoon
break
well why don't you go for another
seven minutes
give or take a couple seconds seven
minutes
mr harding during the the course of time
that you were living and working at that
farm in particular in new jersey are you
aware of whether or not the defendant
was ever married
yes
and did his wife at the time
live at the property
yes
are you aware uh when that relationship
was over whether he had another
relationship
yes and are you familiar with an
individual named mary haskins greg yes
were mary haskins gray and the defendant
involved in a romantic relationship yes
and do you know if they were also
involved in a business relationship
yes
did you know mary haskins gray before
she and the defendant started seeing
each other romantically i did
what was the nature of your relationship
with her
uh
around the time when she and the
defendant started seeing each other
we were
friends but she lived far away so we
weren't close friends
and during the course of time that ms
gray and the defendant started seeing
each other
did she spend more more and more time at
the defendant's properties yes
did that
have any impact on your relationship
with her
we became closer
are you familiar with her having
children
yes and at times would her children
come to visit or stay at the farm for
periods of time yes
did any
so besides yourself
the
defendant either his ex ex-wife
or wife at the time or mary haskins gray
and the working students
did anyone ever live at that property
with any
regularity
sometimes students would come and stay
overnight
dude uh
and i think we already heard some of his
testimony so
hopefully the jury will forgive me but
with respect to running a farm a horse
farm are there a number of vendors that
come to the farm with the regular with
regularity yes who might some of those
vendors be
um
veterinarians for the horses uh dentists
for the horses
farriers or blacksmiths for the horses
as well as
delivery of
horse feed and supplies
and it sounds like from the testimony
you've already given that most of the
clients or people who boarded horses
there did not live at the property
yes correct
were there any sort of gates or other
obstacles to someone driving onto the
property to get back to the barn
no
now when you and michael barissone were
at the farm together at the same time
how frequently would you communicate
frequently
and would that typically be face to face
if you were both there yes
at times did you discuss aspects of
running the farm or or business related
topics
yes
did you also discuss things that were
going on in the equestrian world with
each other
yes
can you tell the jury a little bit about
how involved you were with running the
day-to-day operations at the farm and
i'm specifically talking about that
summer of 2019.
i was very involved
i would
take over almost everything on occasions
when michael would be away
but very involved in the day-to-day
are you familiar with the defendant
having a website to advertise the
business yes and what was the name of
the business
barristone dressage
judge i'd like permission
to show the witness s74 which i believe
has already been admitted into evidence
sure
mr hardin i'm showing you what's been
marked as s74 in evidence
does this look like the generally the
the logo you were familiar with from the
website
yes and do you see a date in the top
left corner of this of august 8 2019
yes
and moving down the uh
the page
who's that a picture of
me
and is that your name underneath the
picture yes
and
was there then as we move a little bit
further down the page
uh some information about your writing
experience as well as some of the things
that you have to offer as part of the
business
yes
i'm going to show you one more
and this is s71 which has already been
admitted into evidence
is s71 also appear to be a
screenshot or
the website with the date of august 8th
2019 in the top left corner yes and
scrolling down
did this website or this page on the
website indicate that to inquire about
lessons or training an individual could
contact mr barrissone ms gray or
yourself
yes
now during the times that you worked
with michael barissone were you ever
ever able to observe anything about his
demeanor related to running the business
yes what would that be
um
certain happiness moments of happiness
or stress
during different times of running the
business
and when you say that
i don't want to put words in your mouth
can you just elaborate on that a little
bit uh moments of stress versus moments
of happiness
[Music]
happiness would be
himself or a student having probably a
particular success in the competition
or
improvements on the staples and stress
would be
you know students not doing as well as
they would like to or horses being sick
or injured
did he ever
have any stresses related to the
finances of running the business i'm
sure yes
can you tell the jury uh in your words
what safe sport is
it's a
organization that oversees
a lot of sports and sporting activities
mostly for conduct
behavior
both bullying and
protecting miners in the sport
and is that something that uh existed at
the time that you first became involved
in equestrian or dressage no
do you recall approximately if you
recall
when that came to be
approximately
2016.
is that something that you were required
to do anything to be licensed or
registered as a competitor you had to
complete yearly online training
classes
now are you aware
from
august 5th
2019
related to an individual named george
morris and a safe sport yes
do you know who george morris is yes can
you tell the jury who george morris is
um
one of the most famous american
show jumping riders and coaches
and do you know if the defendant michael
barisson knew george morse
he did
when
safe sport
gave that punishment to him on august
5th of 2019 objection judge
your seven minutes is up
we're gonna break now and reformulate my
question no well it's it's since there's
an objection rather than keep the jury
i'm gonna dismiss them for their
afternoon break and we can continue all
uh address mr um
blinkist's objection
all right 15 minutes
you
judge might be seated
yes go ahead
all right what's the nature of the
objection mr belunkus
he's testifying he's talking about
mr morris it's clearly hearsay
and i'm not sure what to do
yeah nor am i let's see if mr sheldon
can explain it
judge george morris was given a lifetime
ban that was the nature of the next
question was giving a lifetime ban by
safe sport on august 5th 2019 which
obviously is just two short days before
the
shooting
um
as
what was the ban for
i do not intend to elicit that judge for
prejudicial reasons but it was for
sexual misconduct
i think it certainly is relevant but i
was not intending to elicit that again
because uh
on balance
i recognize that that could be
prejudicial
i don't see the relevance of someone
else being born well if it's mr
barryson's
what's the relationship between mr
barrissone and
this individual mr morris mr morris is
essentially one of his mentors and
someone that he looked up to as a a a
leader in a paradigm of horsemanship in
the community
his entire career to the point where he
would go and watch mr morris coaching
and training even though they were in
different disciplines so that he could
learn
how to be a better coach and trainer
obviously the fact that that person who
he looked up to
so closely was given a lifetime ban from
the sport two days before
with all the other testimony that we've
heard
wow
is there information that mr barroso
knew about that lifetime ban prior to
august 7th at the time it was handed
down on the fifth or sixth he did he
spoke to him judge he spoke to him on
august 5th 2019. so he spoke to him the
scene uh how do you know that
uh
ms ms gray
uh to talk to him about that
and the defendant told that to her
as well as having i believe those
conversations with mr harden
if i may
what the prosecutor is going to try to
do when i have a
transcript of a interview with mr
morris
is that my client
called him i believe on the fifth
and basically after hearing about the
band
according to mr morris
said that michael expressed his
condolences
said he was sorry
the investigator for the prosecutor's
office then starts questioning mr morris
with regards to his ban
mr morris is telling the investigator
not michael barason
that safe sport is being used as a
weapon
you know
people have killed themselves over it
you know it's a horrible uh you know
a body
and basically
he says to the investigator it ruined my
life and then the investigator
interjects to mr morris not mr barrisson
well do you know that lauren cataract
was going to turn michael barrisson into
safe sport and mr morris says that i
quote words to the effect
that would have destroyed his life
there is nothing to indicate that that
statement was ever made to michael
barrasson there's nothing to indicate
that they talked about that
all the prosecutor has is a transcript
of their conversation with mr morris
where he renders an opinion in his mind
after going through what he did which
again was a horrific story as to what
effect that would have on michael
barrasson
and i don't see i don't see how they get
that in to be honest with you i'm not
going there judge no i don't think he's
going there he's going in um
i suppose he's going in you want to get
in the fact that
a mentor of mr owns was banned for life
from the sport he loved
two days before the shooting two days
before the shooting isn't that relevant
to mr barrissone's state of mind no
what problem is that someone else being
a band and then dcp and p shows up at
his house
you don't think that's relevant that his
mentor two days before got a lifetime
ban for sexual misconduct and then dcp
and p shows up
well
everything else you say goes to a state
of mind why shouldn't this if it's a
stressor everything else has been
rejected basically no it's not
just your manner of trying to get it in
has been rejected
and it's hearsay judge how is he going
to get any of this in
which witness has the personal
first-hand knowledge of this ban
well the defendant i suppose do you have
information that the the defendant had
conversations with this witness
he could elicit it from as a defendant
statement if he knew about the ban it's
a phone record then he called them
that's it no
taped conversation no email no text
message well you just said that there
was an expression of condolence on the
part of mr barrison basically that's
what mr morris said judge
not mr barrison
how do you how do you get this in that
the defendant
judge i believe you knew about knew
about the the lifetime ban i believe the
testimony from ms gray which wasn't
objected to when she testified
was that this was explosive news in the
equestrian community when it happened i
would have to go back to my notes to
look at that but she said it was
something that everyone was talking
about
my recollection is that she said that
she test she discussed it with the
defendant
and that the defendant knew who judge
morris knew about that
again my recollection or my anticipation
rather is that mr harden will testify to
that
i
again can can recall ms gray and show
her the text message where she sends the
text message that says
michael to justin mr harden michael just
talked to george
on august 5th 2019. so i don't want to
leave the court to believe that i'm
speculating about whether they had these
conversations
but that would be your say too how do we
how do we know what was said but but
it's it's again i'm not trying to bring
in all of the particulars or the
specifics i have no intent
i i think i have a good faith argument
to argue
as your honor just said that individual
was was given a lifetime ban for sexual
assault
the defendant jumps to a conclusion when
dcp shows up there that warren canara
has called dcp p on him and reported him
for sexual assault and five minutes
later or ten minutes later he's trying
to kill her
that obviously goes to his state of mind
his motivation
so it's not hearsay it goes to show
directly the effect that it had on him
he finds that out and the moment dcp
gets on scene he's going to load a gun
get a gun and kill somebody
toronto he objected to the question as
to what dc cnp said i know but so well
is the dc pnp worker going to testify
i anticipate she's going to testify
and i anticipate she's going to testify
that she was not there to investigate a
report of sexual assault
again the defendant jumped to that
conclusion
because of this report
about george morris it was all over
every equestrian
website newspaper
it was on
all kinds of news outlets
so if his friend killed somebody
mr blinkist you put in the defendant's
state of mind
correct you put that in
are you saying that learning that your
mentor was banned from the sport of or
the equestrian activities
had no effect on mr barrison or didn't
have not even that didn't have the
potential to affect his fragile state of
mind at that time no i don't i don't
think so judge there's nothing that he
never indicated that to anyone to any of
the doctors the state's doctors the
defense doctors you know that wasn't
that that doesn't mean it's not relevant
because it didn't indicate it to a
doctor
there may be other things that doctors
can be cross-examined on things did he
know about this did you know about this
what did he what did he know judge
that he was
that he was bad
what are the circumstances
well it's a lifetime ban two days before
i i think it
it arguably goes to his state of mind
his mental state at that time
now i'm not sure whether getting into
the specifics of it especially because
of all the information so far about ms
cataract notifying safe sport
and ms gray and mr barristone contacting
safe sport
and sending
759 pages
in august to safe sport
well that's part of the case
and if mister barry's own state of mind
is an issue here
whether it affects his state of mind i
don't know whether
i had no idea but
i think it's
an event of some
notoriety that your mentor is banned for
life from the sport
and here comes dcp and p
confronting them
that may certainly impact
how mr barrissone reacted
maybe he saw him going the same way the
state will argue maybe he believed he
was going to be banned now because of
safe sports involved like his mentor and
ruin his life
these are
investigations that literally take
years
the allegations with mr morris
had to do with an allegation of 50 years
prior to that
it's completely different
it's not has nothing to do with the
investigation
it's this defendant learning about it
[Music]
it's this defendant
he learned about it
miss gray said that
mr this witness is going to say the same
thing that he that he learned about it
and i'm also conceding that i'm not
going to get into the particulars of
that because i think that would require
getting into what specifically did the
defendant know versus did it
what i think is indisputable from all of
the evidence and from the witnesses is
that the defendant knew about the
suspension knew about the lifetime ban
that's the fact that i intend to elicit
not the circumstances underlying and
again judge you excluded me getting from
mary haskins gray the fact that a
complaint to save for was in fact filed
against her and she was exonerated
and again we're not getting into the
result but but this is
but mr mr mr belenkus
the reason why i banned that is because
the result as it pertained to ms gray
has absolutely zero relevance
to this defendant's state of mind how
about when when he's told about mr
morris getting a lifetime ban and then
he sees miss gray which basically judged
were the exact same allegations he was
included in that complaint to safe sport
so she's cleared he should have
absolutely no concern about any
complaint being filed against saints
i don't i don't i don't know
i don't know what his concern was
again
you wouldn't let me get into what the
complaint was with mary haskins it was
with mary because you asked it about her
state of mind not his
no you didn't no no you didn't you
didn't ask that mr balance you didn't
bring that up you're bringing it up now
but you didn't bring it up then
and i and the reason why i ruled it out
was because it pertained
to the ruling against her that's how the
question was asked
and i said it's not relevant whatever
the ruling was about her is not relevant
and i even mentioned
the defendant's state of mind is that
issue and you didn't bring up at that
time that the complaint was about him as
well
because because i didn't think the court
would consider bringing up a lifetime
ban of some someone else that has
nothing to do i submit to this case i
think it does it's you you are bringing
in
the fact the whole issue
and you mentioned before here is the
defendant's state of mind
all right and
the state thinks that this may have
impacted his state of mind and it and it
the jury may think the same thing
and again i understand the courts really
i understand your position that that
that's my ruling it comes in not not the
misconduct not the nature of it but just
the fact that mr barisson learned two
days before this incident
that his mentor received a lifetime ban
from safe sport
and again now that you've moved this way
i'm asking the courts to allow me to ask
miss great what the results were with
regards to the complaint against her
from safe sport the exact same complaint
was made against michael barrison and i
submit if one is
who made those complaints
lauren cataract
again if you want to call her in your
case you can call yourself also after
the shooting
this was at some point after the
shooting would not have affected what
was the safe sport ruling
is as it pertains to the defendant's
state of mind at the time of the
shooting not what happened after the
fact
judge so you know the complaint was made
before the shooting the results but
we're talking about the results
what relevance is it if it came in a day
after
or a month after or two months after it
couldn't have affected the defendant's
state of mind because the incident
already happened
i mean that that's abundantly clear so
we'll let it in let's bring um
all right i'm going to take a quick
break and then um we'll address that
issue that i brought up
these cameras
that'd
i don't know i'm sorry
the cameras are stolen
are the cameras still around because
they're still pointing you're good to go
okay
all right
all right
um
um
watching
thank you
can you stop right here
you guys just have to be cognizant about
when we're unhooking him that you guys
don't open that door
6 20 you're good
sorry about that just a funny reminder
that we're still being live streamed so
just be careful of what you say okay
thank you
so used to following that uh the
blinking bloom i know we have enough so
thank you it's really an adjustment no
problem
hey chris did you ask me
is the witness available yes
[Music]
all right you may have a seat sir
all right mr shellhorn are we ready
yeah we're going to address that now the
jury comes in yeah before the joint
comes in
mr horn before we bring the jury in it
did um come to my attention that when
the last witness was testifying
yes
mr harden before we proceed with the
jury it's come to my attention that
before you testified when the last
witness miss gray was testifying you may
have overheard some of that testimony
from
the people um
filming the proceedings is that accurate
i could overhear some of it coming from
outside the doors
when i was sitting outside
outside these doors or where it was
being recorded
both but sitting right there i could
overhear some of what was not muffled
but some of what was coming up okay
what were you able to make and make out
any of the specifics of the no because i
could only hear bits and pieces fine and
you were seated at the um there were
tables outside in the hallway okay
that's where you were seated yes okay
any follow-up um
no thank you judge
i see no problems
maybe we'll have to keep our voices down
then
or have the witnesses have your
detective
i was not i was looking at mr shellhorn
when i said that
i was looking at mr shellhorn and i said
a collective we
um is there any other i know there's
room where we normally put witnesses
um
is being
used
by the news crew there is a bench at
this end
i i think in the future any state's
witnesses should be seated down there
and not not right outside the courtroom
uh the detective indicated to me he
understands that all right thank you
detective
thank you mr horton all right we'll
bring the jurors in
[Music]
since we're continuing
hmm
might be seated everyone will continue
with mr horton's testimony
go ahead mr shellhorn
and that last objection was uh addressed
by the court at the break and the
objection was overruled so
go ahead mr sheldon mr hart and i
apologize if i already asked you these
questions before the break so i'll
ask it again uh
do you know who george morris is i do
who is george morris he was it is a very
famous american show jumper and coach of
the american team
and approximately well have you ever met
him yes do you know if michael barrisson
knows it yes had you ever had any
discussions with the defendant michael
barristone about george morris and his
teaching philosophies and those sorts of
things
yes
are you aware whether the defendant and
mr morris
were friendly with one another they were
now i think i had asked you a question
about whether you were familiar with the
august 5th 2019 punishment that safe
sport handed down to mr morris
are you familiar with that yes and i'm
not going to ask you any specifics about
the
allegations or findings or anything but
are you aware of what the punishment
that he received was
yes what was that a lifetime ban
and is that information something that
was very well known or not very well
known in the equestrian community very
well known do you recall if you and the
defendant mr barristone ever discussed
that when it happened on august 5th or
in the days leading after we did
now i want to draw your attention to the
summer of 2019
you were living and working here at the
new jersey farm during that summer yes
and you indicated that you had lived on
the second floor apartment
of the farmhouse for a number of years
before that summer correct yes
was there some different living
situation in the summer of 2019
yes where were you living in the summer
of 2018
i was staying in a
temporary situation at the stables
now were you personally aware of
anything that had happened at the
farmhouse
that affected parts of the farmhouse
yes what are you aware of
there was a
flooding at the house um the winter
prior
and did you have a chance to at some
point when you came back to new jersey
go into the farmhouse or see what some
of the damages were yes
what parts of the farmhouse were damaged
to your memory
the
ceiling on the first floor
and
most of the first floor was damaged
how was the state of the basement
um
fairly damaged
was it damaged to the extent where
the working students couldn't live there
that summer
yes
now
was that part of the reason why you
weren't living in the second floor
apartment that summer
yes
and who was living in that apartment
that summer
pardon me which apartment uh who was
living in the second floor apartment
during the summer of 2019.
lauren and her boyfriend rob
and in case i didn't ask you at the
beginning of the direct examination
uh who is lauren
lauren kanreck and who's rob
robert goodwin
now who's this was it your decision to
move out of that apartment
no
how did you feel about moving out of
that apartment
objection relevance
what's the relevance of it
i think as we've talked about it goes to
the state of mind of individuals at the
barn and
whether or not that had any impact on
the defendant
i don't think i don't think mr um
horned state of mind is an issue in this
case so
i'll sustain the objection
with respect to uh lauren cantarek
what was her what was your knowledge of
her involvement and presence at the farm
she was there to train
are you aware if she owned any horses
yes and do you recall how many horses
she had
to my recollection she started with
three
were those horses and when you reference
three
would that be to the best of your
recollection horses that were boarded at
the farm
when she started and then that number
increased
over her time there
did you have any uh professional or
working relationship with her yes and
what was that there were certain uh
times during her time there that i would
help her with her horses
and you indicated earlier an individual
named rob rob goodwin
yes who is rob goodwin with respect to
lauren canary her boyfriend fiance
did you have any sort of a professional
relationship with rob
only to the extent that he would um
assist her with the horses
do you remember approximately when they
first started working with michael
barissone or when they first came to one
of his farms
to the best of my memory it was the
spring of 2018.
and during the course of time that
they were boarding horses and training
with michael barissone uh what was the
nature of your personal or social
relationship with either of them
it varied over time
meaning what just in general
meaning uh there were times where we
were
quite social in times where we had no
social interaction
did you have any
direct or specific knowledge of the
agreement that ms canarack or mr goodwin
had with the defendant
at a general
i think he can testify based on his
observations judge
well if it's his personal observations
not not what he heard from someone else
no i'm trying to elicit that he didn't i
think he said he didn't have direct or
specific knowledge so i'm going to ask
him his observations right as long as
it's crouched in those terms
so you indicated that you knew that ms
kanorek had
a number of horses sported at the farm
yes and also i think you indicated that
she was there to train yes would that
have been for
herself as a rider for her horses
or a combination of the two a
combination
are you aware of whether or not uh ms
cantorek was paying any money
to the defendant uh
with respect to those services
that question goes to your own personal
knowledge not what you may have heard
from someone else did you have any
personal knowledge of that it was my
understanding that she was
and you indicated that uh
ms canarac and mr goodwin were living in
the farmhouse that summer of 2019
yes do you have any personal knowledge
of the circumstances of them coming to
live there
coming to live at the apartment or at
the farm
were you a party or were you part of any
conversations about what led to them
living at the
farm well hold on hold on
were you part of any negotiations
yourself with regard to
ms canorack and mr goodwin staying at
the farm
no
that's the answer
and so any information you have about it
came from other sources other than your
personal knowledge and interactions all
right
all right move on mr shellhorn
in you indicated that your relationship
with them uh
fluctuated yeah what was the the state
of your working or professional
relationship with warren canorack in
august of 2019
could you repeat the question what was
the state of your working or
professional relationship with lauren
canarack in this
august of 2019.
i would at that time i was not uh
helping with her with her horses or her
riding
and are you aware from living at the
property
how would you describe the state of
things at the property in august of 2019
extremely tense
now i think you indicated that the
working students
were not living at the farmhouse that
summer
correct and you may have already
answered this i apologize where were
they living
they were living in various locations
around the stables or the club room of
the of the farm
do you know
whether
michael barissone and mary haskins gray
were living together during that summer
they were do you know where they were
living at least at the beginning of that
summer season
uh
also in the farmhouse at the
on the farm do you know what
living area they were living in
to the best of my recollection the main
floor
are you aware whether at some point they
moved out of that house
yes do you know where they went
they went also to the stables the barn
do you recall if anyone else was staying
at the barn who
didn't live there on a more regular
basis at the beginning of august 2019
uh richard gray
who did you know that to be um the
father of mary haskins gray
had ruth cox ever come back to the farm
yes and are you aware whether she was
there on an overnight basis at some
point during august 2019 she was
are you aware whether michael barrasso
never met with a lawyer during august of
2019
yes were you present for any of those
meetings no
during the course of time that warren
canorak and rob goodwin were at the farm
meaning either new jersey or florida did
you ever hear lauren canaract make any
direct threats of violence to michael
barrison
no
did you ever hear mike uh robert goodwin
make any direct threats of violence to
michael barrison
no
working with the defendant michael
barissone for the number of years that
you did
did you ever see or hear him lose his
temper
yes
and what would uh a typical reaction be
if you lost this template
be very vocal
i want to draw your attention to
wednesday of august 7th do you recall
what you were doing that day
specifically in the early afternoon
i was uh working horses
riding
do you recall where you were doing that
uh in the um
in the covered arena on the farm
do you recall if you spoke or interacted
with michael barristone at all that day
earlier in the day
do you recall
generally what his demeanor was
out of his mind
do you recall speaking to him at all or
interacting with him that afternoon
did you see him yelling or otherwise
carrying on that day i did not did you
hear or see him running around the farm
or the clubhouse or the bar i did not
up until the events of the middle of the
afternoon on august 7th would you say
that that was more or less an ordinary
day at the farm
in terms of your day-to-day work for me
yes
now at some point on august 7th did you
become aware that police were at the
property
i did do you recall in general how you
became aware of that
i believe i saw lights
first over the hill
now do you have any personal knowledge
of what occurred at the farmhouse that
afternoon i do not
and do you still have any ongoing
business with michael verasam
i still operate a portion of my business
from his
farm in florida
i don't have any further questions for
mr hardin thank you all right
cross-examination
mr hardened up
when lauren cataract and her
boyfriend robert goodwin
first came to the property
you were very friendly with them correct
correct
we've been socialized with them correct
correct
and can i assume that uh
that relationship changed at some point
yes
uh was laurent cataract causing problems
at barrisone dressage
yes
was she creating a toxic environment
based on your personal observations
yes
you indicated that you were training her
when she first
joined
uh i i believe it wasn't when she first
joined okay we're at some point at some
point yes you started training her and
did she always show up to her lessons
no
did she come at
late hours to the barn or stable area
after hours
she had
and did that create a problem to
all the people that were living in that
area
it did it
it did
and and were you aware of
the social media posts being posted by
lauren cataract i was and
how did those social media posts affect
michael barrisson
uh
i'm going to object to the formula
question
i'll refrain yeah why don't you rephrase
it
you were aware that lauren conoract was
posting things on
social media correct correct
did you ever talk to michael barrisson
about films not specifically did you
have a discussion regarding that just
answer yes or no yes
and
what effect did you observe
with respect
to michael barrasson
with respect to those
um they made him extremely paranoid and
fearful for the
um the farm and everything on it
now
you indicated on direct that he was
living in the farmhouse
underneath cataract and goodwin
yes
at some point of time he moved out of
there
and started living
not in his house but in the
club area in the stables correct yes did
you have a discussion with him regarding
that move
yes
and can you tell me what effect
you observed with respect to michael
barrisson
after
that incident
he was too fearful to be in his own home
that's based on your observations yes
he physically showed
what you recognized as fear correct yes
now this woman cox that the prosecutor
referred to did you have discussions
with her with regards to what was going
on
yes
did you observe fear
objection
what's the basis for the objection the
ongoing objection judge the state of
mind of other individuals is not
relevant i think you've made that ruling
a number of times
what's the relevance of cox's state of
mind isn't the issue mr barrison
shows the overall
toxic environment that affected
everyone and if it affects cox obviously
it would affect mr barroson more because
he's dealing with that
let's not get into that mr
balinkis
it's not a that's not a proper comment
i'll i'll i'll allow the question
and answer
did you observe fear in mrs cox
yes was she sleeping in these stables
in front of her horse because of that
hold on a second now that's going a
little too far mr bolenkas
you're asking him to opine on why she
was doing something that's not within
his province
if he saw her sleep in there he can say
i saw her sleeping there and when that
happened but not the reasons that's
something internal to her
did you see
miss cox sleeping
in her stalls
in front of her horse
yes
i didn't ask you what
the content was but did you have a
discussion with her with regards to that
just answer yes or no did you have a
discussion with miss cox all right he
did next question
now
that's safe in the office um you
indicated that you occasionally had
access to it yes
um
was the safe ever left open
no to your knowledge not to my knowledge
no
did you ever see mary haskins go into
that safe
yes
do you know how she got the combination
to that safe
no
now the prosecutor showed you pictures
of the
stable area where the horses are
housed
is there a rubber floor
in that
area yes and what's the purpose of that
um so the horses don't slip on the
concrete
now
you indicated that it was your
understanding that uh
strikeout
to your knowledge was lauren carrack
paying
for her living accommodations
hold on
what wasn't that objected to when
i asked that question and it was
objective
generally speaking yes
not details
was lauren cataract the only
client on the property
that was living there full time
yes
did you find that unusual
it was not normal
now
you indicated that in august of 2019
that
it was extremely tense
[Music]
yes
and was intense because of cataract and
goodwin
yes you indicated that mary gray's
father came up
do you know why he came up
from personal knowledge
not from what other people told you
she wanted him there to feel so she felt
safer
you were at the uh staples the morning
of the seventh correct
yes
was there a incident between robert
goodwin and the blacksmith or furrier on
that morning yes
and we're not going to ask you what were
any statements made
that you're aware of by robert goodwin
yes
now you indicated that
when michael barrison loses his temper
he becomes vocal
yes raises his voice correct yes maybe
yells a little bit correct
yes
have you ever seen him get physical
absolutely not
now
leading up to the days of the shooting
did you see a
significant mental decline in michael
barrasso objection
he can't testify about that mr balinkus
he's not an expert witness
can you describe your observations
of michael barrasso
say for the last two or three days prior
to the shooting
i would say he was in an almost
catatonic state
hadn't been sleeping eating
um
glazed overlooking his eyes just zombies
no shaving no
was he walking the property at night
to your knowledge
yeah did you did you see that yourself
in other words not what you heard you
saw it yourself yes
very good
was he desponding
explain sorry
despondent
uh depressed
extremely
was he able
to perform
the everyday functions
normally associated with running his
business
no the first time in 18 years i had seen
him that way
did he cancel clinics
yes
did he show up to to ride when he uh
normally did no
did he withdraw
absolutely
were you concerned about him based on
your observations 100
i have nothing further on any redirect
just briefly your honor uh
mr hardin from having known
mr barrissone for the length of time
that you did
uh would it be fair to say that he
did have other emotional or mental
struggles during the time you knew him
with for example anxiety
yes and that existed before he met ms
canaric
yes he also had issues with depression
yes and that existed before he met her
yes
nothing further judgment all right
one more question
based on based on that yes absolutely
the
observations of depression and anxiety
that you observed
on prior occasions
were these
observations
leading up to the day of the shooting
much much worse
extremely worse
all right you may step down thank you
did matt look out in the hall and just
make sure the next witness is here sure
go to the state we'll next call ruth cox
watch your stuff please
step up to the table
okay
good afternoon miss cox how are you i'm
fine thank you uh please remain standing
for a moment if you could place your
left hand on the bible please raise your
right hand my court clerk will
administer an oath to you do you swear
the presence of almighty god that the
testimony you give to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes ma'am please state your name
and spell your last name for the record
ruth pence cox my last name is c-o-x
thank you
all right miss cox can you have a seat
thank you
please keep your voice up nice and loud
so we have jurors in the jury box and
also in the first two rows in the
gallery
that microphone um
just records doesn't amplify your voice
okay so keep your voice up if i'm not
speaking loud enough please let me know
all right and jurors you don't hear
anything please just raise your hand and
we'll have the witness raise your voice
a little bit
and if you don't understand a question
miss cox posed by one of the attorneys
or the court if i happen to ask a
question just indicate you don't
understand that's fine i don't want you
answering a question if you don't
understand it okay all right very good
go ahead mr shellhorn thank you
could you please introduce yourself to
the jury and tell them where you live
yes you want me to give my name again
if if you would okay dr ruth cox and i
live in new bern north carolina
and dr cox do you know michael barrisson
yes sir i do do you see him in court
today yes sir would you identify him by
an article clothing he's wearing
a dark-colored tie
she's identified by climbing all right
uh for the record uh miss cox has
identified the defendant mr barrissone
dr cox do you also know an individual or
know of an individual named warren
kenner i do and do you know her through
your association with michael barisson i
do
approximately how many times would you
say that you've ever interacted with him
maybe three times
do you know an individual named robert
goodwin yes and do you know her of him
through your association with michael
barcelona yes
i want to direct your attention back to
august of 2019 were you in new jersey at
the beginning of the month of august
2019. i was
specifically do you recall where you
were
you mean at his stables is that the
question you're asking where were you
staying i was staying at his stables yes
sir meaning the defendant michael
barrett yes michael bayer's unstable yes
sir do you recall where that stable is
located in long valley
and on august 4th or august 5th were you
having a conversation with the defendant
in the stables on that property yes sir
i was did he ask you for something yes
sir what did he ask you for
uh he wanted to see a gun that i had in
my car
do you recall what kind of gun that was
it is a nine millimeter ruger it's a
small pistol
and is there do you recall what color or
coloring it was
uh yes sir the bottom part of it is a
pinkish in color like pink camo
if
you know what i mean yes sir yes
short for camouflage camo yes yes yes
sir camouflage yes go ahead mr thank you
doctor
uh
did uh he take that handgun from you
during the course of that conversation
yes sir he did and on august 7th of 2019
are you aware that an incident occurred
at the farmhouse on that property
yes sir i am do you have any personal
knowledge of that
of what happened outside the farmhouse
i was not present to it i know that
there was a shooting
did you come to find that out after the
fact yes after the fact yes sir meaning
you didn't witness what actually
happened absolutely not
now at some point on august 7th were you
still at the stable in the clubhouse
when the police came yes sir i was and
did you have a
conversation with them or were you
interviewed by the police on that day
yes sir i was that after that afternoon
and that evening and did you come to
find out at some point after the
shooting that that handgun that you gave
to the defendant had been recovered by
the police on the property unfortunately
sir i did
dr cox i want to ask you some questions
uh about that weapon uh were you charged
with a crime related to that firearm yes
sir i was
do you recall what the specific charge
was that you were charged with
i don't know the legal terms that you
would use but i'm sure that you could
tell me but it had to do with bringing a
weapon into your state
and did it also have to do with
unlawfully transferring it to another
person yes sir it did now do you recall
appearing before judge taylor on
december 13th 2021 on a zoom or a
virtual hearing yes sir i did and do you
recall
let me rephrase that question were you
represented by an attorney yes sir i was
do you recall what the purpose of that
hearing on december 13th was yes the
purpose was to put
be put on a program
a pretrial intervention program
and what is your understanding of what
uh pre-trial intervention is
uh it's a you know i'm not going to use
legal terms because i don't know all the
legal terms but it is a type of
probation in which i will
respond to a probation officer which i
have come to make contact with and i
will follow all the rules and
regulations that i'm asked to do
according to all the documents that i
signed related to that now do you recall
what the maximum punishment you could
have gotten if you didn't enter into pti
was for that crime
uh i think according to your laws i
could have gotten 18 months in
uh jail
and what was the
period of supervision
or or probationary supervision that you
were given as part of the pti 36 months
have you been compliant with the
supervision at this point absolutely
sir i have
did you go over the pti order that was
signed by you and me and judge taylor
yes sir and that was also signed by your
lawyer yes sir
and did that also require you to forfeit
or surrender the firearm that we were
just discussing yes sir
have you met with me and other members
of my office at times over
zoom or teams or something like that yes
sir
and at times was your attorney present
for some of those meetings yes sir
now i want to draw your attention back
to
michael barissone can you tell the jury
approximately when it is that you first
met him
i met him about five years before the
incident happened
down in new bern north carolina
and do you recall what the circumstances
of that meeting were in newburgh yes sir
i owned a horse with mary haskins gray
and we were looking for someone to help
us with this horse because we thought he
had great potential
mary haskins had known michael and
thought that he would be helpful to us
and she had asked him to come down there
to a horse clinic where there would be
multiple lessons that he would give and
as you know he's an olympian and a very
good horseman and people would be
interested to come and take lessons from
him and that's how i first met him
over time did you get to know him
better yes sir i did and did you also
enter into a co-ownership agreement of a
horse with him yes sir i did what was
the horse that you owned together with
the defendant uh it was a fall named
lady guardian
and i'm sure everybody buys horses for
different reasons what's the reason that
you were would buy a horse or invest in
a horse
uh we thought this horse would have a
potential for dressage and
mary haskins would be the person who
would be his rider
and did you have any feelings about
michael barrisson being the trainer of
that horse
i had positive feelings about that yes
sir
over the course of time uh that you knew
the defendant and you
entered into some of these business
arrangements with him did your
relationship with him move beyond just
business and become more of a friendship
yes sir
now i think you indicated that you owned
a horse or horses with
mary haskins gray yes sir do you recall
how many horses you owned with her two
what were the names of those horses don
devone was one horse and jolina was the
second horse
did you own any other horses besides don
devone jolina or lady garden no sir
where were those horses boarded they
were boarded at michael bear's own
stables
did you pay mr barrisone with respect to
the boarding yes sir i did did you pay
him as well for training the horses yes
sir
now i think you indicated already that
you are familiar with the
long valley farm
yes sir are you familiar with whether or
not michael barason owns another stabler
farm elsewhere yes sir where is that
loxahatchee florida and did you have an
opportunity during the course of your
relationship with uh michael barisson to
visit both of those farms at times yes
sir
is it fair to say
those visits went from being strictly
business to being business and personal
or social yes
did you ever stay overnight in new
jersey when you came to visit yes sir
where would you typically stay if if
there was a typical place
well i would i would stay somewhere on
the farm there were different
opportunities for places for me to spend
the night so i would usually stay on the
farm at some place it would change from
time to time time to time
can you generally describe for the jury
they've already seen some diagrams of
the property but what's your
recollection of the general layout or
some of the features of the property
it's a lovely piece of property um from
the road uh there's a hill that goes up
to to the top obviously of the hill
there's a historic house that's there
that's several stories high which he
restored up at the top on the other side
of the hill there's a large horse
complex that includes a club room
and behind that club room there's a
lovely indoor arena
to the left of that club room there is a
garage in which michael had his cars he
loved antiques cars to the right there
was a long stables that came to the
right behind all of that there was
another small stables over there
and you went down the hill on the other
side and below that was where the young
slop was kept and there was a small
stable down there that was used for
feeding them and giving them hay
and there were several outdoor
paddocks and there was also an outdoor
dressage arena over to the right
now you indicated that if you're driving
on the
driveway that you would come up to a
rise or a hill
if you went over the hill to where the
stables and the clubhouse and that sort
of thing are could you see to the
farmhouse
you could see the upper part of the of
the farmhouse yes i mean it was like
three stories high so you could see the
upper part of the farmhouse yes sir
now you described a little bit about the
uh the layout of the stable and the club
room
what are some of your distinctive
memories of the club room area
um
the club room had a very long table in
the middle of it it had furniture that
you could sit and look out from the from
the club room into the dressage arena
which was a very nice thing particularly
when it got chillier there was a kitchen
uh very often there were parties in
there like just an example july the 4th
we usually had a cookout there was a
a porch on the front as you walked into
the club room so there were various
social activities that would happen in
that club room
what kind of things do you remember
would be hanging on the walls in that
club room
uh there was memorability uh that
michael had from his various
years
in his horse his horse world
uh there were various championship
ribbons that he had
there were letters from people that he
had helped in the horse world thanking
him for helping him on the walls
now
when you weren't at the property or
weren't at one of the farms how
frequently would you communicate with
the defendant
i i did not commute i was just trying to
think on how to answer that i did not
communicate with him very often
um i'm more because mary haskins was
later
uh living up there i would more
communicate with her
now what was your experience or let me
ask you some questions about your
experience related to
the the business that michael verizon
was running
do you know how many different stalls
there were at the new jersey farm for
horses for example
i never counted
um
i'm good
okay i'm going to say 20 plus
and what was your experience with uh
with with the number of horses that may
be in those stalls
i'm not sure what you're asking me in
other words uh were the stalls typically
more full more empty or something in the
middle oh absolutely more full
uh he had some of his horses and he had
a lot of horses like mine who he had
clients uh for
so it was mainly full
are you aware whether he had any
employees or people working for him yes
sir what was your understanding
he had he had a gentleman who mucked out
the stalls in the morning
and he he usually had one or two working
students
what did you know the working students
to do based on your observations or what
you saw
they would groom the horses they would
get the horses tacked up and saddled to
be ridden and there was a constant
exchange of horses between
when michael was there between michael
between mary haskins and between justin
and so the working students took care of
that they also took care of the feeding
now you introduce yourself as a doctor
yes sir can you tell the jury a little
bit about your own professional
experience and what you do for a living
okay do you want me to talk about the
degrees that i hold is that what you're
asking me to do what's what's your edu
what's your background in education okay
all right so
i hold a diploma degree in nursing which
is a three-year degree i have a bachelor
of science in nursing i have a master's
of science in psych mental health
nursing
i have a phd degree in marriage and
family therapy
and i am a family nurse practitioner and
a psych mental health practitioner
and in a nutshell what do you do
now
what is your occupation now what's your
practice entail okay so uh in the town
that i live in i work for several
different agencies there
uh
doing medication management and also
doing individual and family
therapy were you ever engaged in a
formal professional relationship based
on your position with michael barrasson
no sir i was not
did you ever interact with him in that
regard on a personal or a friendly level
please ask that question in a different
way
did you ever uh interact with him or
have any dealings with him
on a on a personal level that drew on
your professional background yes
based on the period of time that you
knew the defendant did you ever observe
anything
when you were with him
related to his running the business
yes sir what might that be
um i observed how he managed his time
how he managed his clinics
his buying of selling of hay
um his
interest in in different types of feed
uh
those type things
did you ever have any observations or
even talk to him
with regard to any concerns he had about
his finances or about the financial
aspects of running a business
we discussed that at times because he
was always very cognizant of being able
to fund this large organization which is
he alone was funding so
yes we discussed that at times
that sort of leads in into my next
question set of questions which is about
how expensive it can be to own a horse
how much do you want to spend
well what uh what are some factors that
could affect how much a a horse costs to
buy
well the factors would be their breeding
would be how you want to use this horse
if you just want a horse that you can
trail ride then you're not looking at a
real expensive horse the kinds of horses
that were there at those stables the
kind of horses that myself and mh were
interested in were much much higher
priced horses that we were looking
forward to doing
the top level dressage national and
international
competition and what are some of the
ongoing expenses that you may have after
you
buy the horse oh buying the horse was
just the simple thing
so then you have
feed you have hay
you have watering you have ferry bills
you have vet bills you have tack
you have boarding if you're going to
boarding somewhere you have training you
need a trailer you need a truck
does that help you
is that just the tip of the iceberg yeah
that's why i'm smiling yes
now you indicated that your purpose in
wanting to buy those horses and your
aspirations with the horses was to get
them to the highest levels if possible
absolutely
what role or effect does a trainer have
in trying to accomplish a goal like that
oh the trainer
is has a lot of responsibility in terms
of their understanding of what it takes
to do that both for the horse and for
the rider and the experience that they
had had to be able to do that
and based on your experience in the
equestrian industry
similar to how you said if you have
aspirations for a horse it may cost more
does it cost more for a better trainer
oh absolutely yes sir
where would you or how would you
evaluate the defendant as a trainer
based on your observations exceptional
now i want to direct your attention and
ask you some questions about the gun
you mentioned
earlier about owning a gun
and can you remind the jury what kind of
a gun that was
it was a nine millimeter ruger very
small handgun
do you remember when you bought that gun
approximately
sometime in the beginning of 2016.
did you recall where you purchased it
what state
no sir i do not
where were you living at the time i was
living in north carolina
and can you describe for the jury what
were some of the steps that you had to
take in order to be able to purchase the
gun
yes sir the gun that i was looking for
was very difficult to find because it
was a small gun so i went on the
internet
and called and contacted various
dealers pawn shops and it ended up that
this gun came from i can tell you
somewhere in the midwest it was sent
from there to a pawn shop in newbern
now did you
just find the gun order it online and
then walk into the pawn shop in newborn
new burn and pick it up
i did go in
i did go in and pick it up but i had to
sign for it
did you have to do any other paperwork
or go through any sort of checks or
anything like that an application
process in order to buy the gun
yes sir i did in north carolina
you can have a concealed carry permit
and for in north carolina for that you
have to go to a class
for that
then you have to go through the
sheriff's department to apply
for the concealed carry permit
i had to be fingerprinted
i had to fill out various forms right
now i don't remember how many but it
just wasn't one or two and then you had
to have background check checks done
both in the criminal system and in the
mental health system
and after all that comes back is that
when you get some sort of a permit and
you're allowed to go pick up the gun yes
sir
now you indicated that you wanted to
purchase this particular gun uh what was
the reason you wanted to buy this
specific gun i have a very small hand
very small fingers so i needed a gun
that had a very small grip
what was the reason that you bought the
gun
uh i was going to do part target
shooting i have some friends that have
guns and so
we were interested in doing that
together
did you ever uh travel with the gun
uh at times i did yes and specifically
did you ever travel with the gun when
you would come up from new bern to the
long valley farm i did at times
due to safety issues because i would
leave newborn after work in the
afternoon and there is no straight way
to drive from newburn to long valley so
you have to in three or four o'clock in
the morning i'm driving through the
countryside in the dark and uh so at
times when that would be happening yes i
would have that with me
what's the approximate amount of time it
would take you to drive from newburn to
long valley uh between 11 and 12 hours
did you ever take the gun with you when
you would go down to the farm in
loxahatchee no sir i did not
can you tell the jury when you would
travel with the gun how would you
transport it
uh so the gun itself was transported um
with a
in the clip with a plastic clip
in the magazine that came with the gun
so the gun was not loaded the gun was in
a pouch by itself
i had a truck at that time
and so
we were taught in a in our uh course
that the best place to put the gun is in
the trunk of your car and since i do not
have a trunk uh in the car it was in the
back seat
on the passenger side against the door
in the back seat which would be
the farthest away you know for me to if
i if i wanted to try and get it i could
not reach it
now you indicated that you would keep
that orange
plastic magazine inside the gun yes sir
did the gun come with any other uh
magazines to put bullets into
yes sir it came with one
how many did you typically have with the
gun two
did the gun have any sort of a case or
anything else
you mean when it when i bought it when
you bought it no it did not come in a
cage did you buy a case for it yes sir i
did what kind of case did you buy it was
a um
material plastic case that had a zipper
uh and the inside was had like velvet
material you know crush material for the
gun and a pocket for the gun on the
outside there was a zipper for the
magazines
now
judge if i could approach
certainly
judge for the record i'm going to
hand forward s-177 i believe that's
already in evidence it is s-181 already
in evidence
s 202 in evidence and s 178 which is not
yet in evidence but i would like to
offer it at this time
uh
170 um
it's 179 that hasn't been admitted yet
170 178 178 is admitted in evidence the
other items are already in evidence
dr cox if we could start with the uh
white box there
that should have a red sticker on it
that says
s177
yes sir
can you open that up
please
and from looking at that what is it
it's a ruger
pistol
and is that the same uh ruger pistol
that you
uh purchased back sometime in 2016
if it's the same serial number yes sir
it is can you see the serial number
there
yes i can
is that the same serial number or do you
want to look at something to refresh
your memory
i i don't i don't have that number in my
mind
but i know but i know that you all
checked it out
well just for purposes of the record i'm
going to show you uh
i think it's
s-173 which i'll stipulate that sort of
gun
why
parties are stipulating that uh the
cereal mat the serial number on that gun
matches the record so it is in fact your
gun the parties have stipulated to that
right
yes sir it is my girl
mr shellhorn did you catch the witness's
answer she did acknowledge that that was
in fact her gun thank you all right very
good move on next question
dr cox if you could just hold that gun
up and show it to the jury
and if it helps you to stand up you
could do that too
you want me to walk around
you've already seen it
yeah just sold it off
i'm sure they appreciate your offer
now dr cox win and you can put it down
thank you
when you uh had that gun on august in
the beginning of august of 2019 and the
defendant took it from you
did it have all those various safety
mechanisms on it no sir it did not
i apologize i forgot to hand up s-191
so i'm going to hand that out and ask if
that could be identified at this time
yeah it should be moved into evidence at
this time
i think it's already in evidence
s191
yes it is
it is it's in evidence dr cox i'm going
to ask you what s 191 if you could open
that
and
take out what's in that bag
what is that
it is a gun case
and that's the gun case you indicated
earlier it didn't come with the gun but
you bought it on your own
now
would it be typical for you to travel
from north carolina to new jersey
if you had the gun with you to have it
in that case yes sir would you have that
case inside anything else when you would
travel
uh i have a i have a backpack
[Music]
that contains
uh for instance the gun cleaning
equipment and then earphones uh that are
to be used when you
do target shooting
uh was there anything else in there did
you ever carry ammunition yes there'd be
ammunition in there as well yes
now
have you
have been having owned that gun
for a number of years have you actually
shot that gun yes sir i have can you
describe for the jury
when you would get to for example a
shooting range
what would be the steps that you would
take to prepare that gun to shoot
uh there would be a table out at the
range
and so uh we have object for relevance
what's the relevance mr um shellhorn
judge state of mind is an issue this
case and certainly this is the gun that
the state is alleging was used in the
shooting i think the process that would
go into shooting the gun by someone who
has actual knowledge of shooting the gun
is relevant
i'll allow it overall
i should answer yes go ahead you can
answer man
dr cox don't ask me ask the judge yes
yes no that's all right no worries yes
you can answer i won't do that again
it's okay
go ahead you can answer the question yes
you can there would be a table there and
there were
multiple people
there shooting and there would be a
range officer and the officer would give
us certain commands about what to do
with the gun reminding us always to put
the gun going downrange and they would
tell us when we could put the clip in
and when the range was hot and when the
range was cold
backing up just a little bit then when
you would get there
to the range and you were going to shoot
the gun
uh when you arrived there would it have
that orange plastic magazine still in
the gun
yes sir it would
and so you would have to remove that yes
sir what's the process that goes into
removing that orange
plastic clip from the gun well on the
side of the gun there's a little button
that lets the clip come out so you'd
have to push that button to get the clip
to come out judge if i could just uh
approach and
sure go ahead
i'm sure you can't hold this up at the
same time but i'm going to ask if you
can point out
do you see
where that would be
it's over it's over on the other side
it's on the other side
and
can you point out to the jury the
general area on the other side where
that would be so it'd be on this side on
the other side so you could take your
thumb and you can push that and it would
drop the clip out and do you have s202
in front of you there i think it's this
right here
can you just open that up
is that your look like your orange clip
absolutely so where would that go or
where would that fall out of so that
would fall out here
and the purpose of that is what safety
so you would have to take that out of
the gun before you could load bullets oh
absolutely yes sir
when you would typically get to the
range dr cox would you have bullets
loaded into the magazine or would you
have to do that when you got to the
range tissue um i usually carried one or
two magazines in this case we're in the
zipper thing
so
i may have one magazine that was loaded
and the other magazine i would have to
load
and i'll just ask you if you could uh
look at s177
which is one of those folders in front
of you or envelopes in front of you
i got a 178 and a 181 i'm sorry
178.
does that appear to be one of the
magazines for your gun yes sir and are
there bullets in that right now yes sir
there are
do you recall if there were bullets in
that magazine when you gave it to
michael barrison
there would have been one of the
magazines with there were two magazines
one of them would would surely have had
the bullets in it the other one may not
have had
you can put that back in the uh
now you indicated it maybe
you would typically have ammunition not
in that case that's in front of you
that's s 191 but in your backpack in
your car yes sir
do you recall what kind of ammunition
you would typically buy
it would be nine millimeter
and would you buy a particular brand or
something else no sir
because all i was doing was target
shooting i bought the cheapest bullets
that were out there in in north carolina
you can buy bullets at various different
places so
if i came across some i would buy them
judge if i can approach again
sure dr cox i'm going to show you what's
been marked as s 190
and i'll
leave that if you could just take that
out
do you recognize
s-190
i know what it is
yes sir
it's a is a box of bullets do you know
if that box of bullets was was yours or
not
no sir i do not know did you give any
bullets or ammunition to michael
barissone
in a box or that sort of thing
absolutely sir i did not all right you
can put that back in the envelope thank
you
doctor i'm going to ask you some
questions about august of 2019.
all august win of 2019
2009
[Music]
i think you indicated that you knew of
lauren canareck and rob goodwin through
your association with michael barrisson
yes sir
did you have any
did you have any personal knowledge of
whatever agreements or arrangements they
had with michael barrisson yes sir what
was your personal knowledge
the the small bit of knowledge that i
had was that
uh michael had an arrangement with
lauren and her family
that
i'm judge it's got to be your sake
where did you acquire your knowledge
from dr cox where did i yeah did you
hear it from somebody michael bearson
all right
um
it's not hearsay it comes from the
defendant well it's hearsay but there's
a um
exception that they hear say well
803 b
would let it in
uh b1 in particular go ahead i'm sorry
to cut you off go ahead ask the question
again mr sheldhorn dr cox did you have
conversations with michael barason about
the nature of the business relationship
he had with lauren canorack or robert
goodwin or their family yes sir what was
your understanding from the defendant of
that relationship
lauren had several horses there that she
was working with uh with michael
bearstown
and my understanding was that they
exchanged part of that board cost
for rob to do some work
at michael's property
and did you observe around the property
what some of that work was yes sir i did
and in general terms what what did that
consist of it is consisted of in the
stable some new wiring new lights and uh
putting in a ceiling in that stable
and uh in the home down near the street
working on the cellar that was there to
produce some new bedrooms and some new
plumbing there
do you remember when you came back
to new jersey in august of 2019 what day
it would either have been a thursday or
a friday
if i uh told you it was approximately
august 2nd
what's that sound
i think it was friday
it was a little bit leading this is
trying to refresh your memory judge all
right what do you have something
other than your own memory you can
refresh your memory with it i ask the
court to take
judicial notice of uh
what's the date
i'm just double checking so i make the
record clear your honor
that that august
august 2nd was a friday judge according
to the calendar on my computer yes i
will take i have a
computer as well
i see a calendar
and it is
august 2nd was a friday
does that sound generally consistent
with your recollection yes sir that
would be
when you arrived back to the property
on that date
what was your observation about the
state of people and things going on at
the property
uh it was a very tense situation
people were worried
unsure about what
was going to be happening
people were hesitant about
kind of going some goings and comings
but generally everybody was upset
when you got back to the property did
you know all of the specific details of
what had been going on or was that just
basically your general impression when
you got here
i didn't know all the details but i
i understood that there was conflict
between michael bearson
and um
lauren canary
now over the next several days from the
time you got there
uh
would you say that things
got better got worse or stayed the same
oh no sir they got much much worse day
after day after day
were you ever present at uh the property
when michael barrasson's lawyer came
yes sir
and do you recall if you were a party to
or a part of any conversation or meeting
you would have had with the lawyer yes
sir
and without getting into the specifics
of what anyone said during that meeting
what was your general impression of the
the purpose for the meeting jackson
jokes it has to be based on this yeah it
is based on hearsay
where did the meeting take place miss
cox uh it took place in the club room at
the stables were you present yes sir i
was pregnant who else was present
uh michael was there i believe mary
haskins was there the lawyer was there
and
it could have been that mary haskins
father was there
because he had come up to the staples
right
approximately how long was the
conversation
uh the conversation was probably half an
hour 45 minutes
all right thank you
during the uh mr shellhorn i think i i
think
i'm going to sustain them
any further questioning about it would
elicit here say statements of others so
it's a classic hearsay and therefore not
admissible judge can i get a date for
that uh
conversation
do you recall the date dr cox oh
absolutely not so
go ahead mr shellhorn
now doctor i want to ask you some
specific questions about that
conversation that you had with uh with
michael barrasson about the gun
do you recall where on the property that
conversation happened i do where was
that
uh it was in the uh long aisle
of all those stables up near
uh the wash stalls outside of don
devone's
stable
judge i would like to show a photo it's
s319
i don't believe that that has been
identified or moved into evidence at
this time
i apologize it has i think it was with
the last witness
yes 319 is in evidence
doctor i think that may be on your
screen in front of you as well too if
that's easier for you that is easier yes
sir um
what is s-319 a picture of
this is a picture of the long aisle on
the right hand side of the stables where
the
majority of the stables were and what's
at the far end of the aisle there
so at the far end there are two wash
stalls on the right and where you see
that kind of black hole it goes out into
a docking bay
and at that end of the
at that end of the aisle if you were to
take a left into that hallway where does
that go
so when you got to the end of this aisle
if you went left yes you went into the
indoor arena
and the clubhouse was right in front of
that and the clubhouse was in front of
that
where was the the stall where don devone
your horse was uh was boarded
his would have been so if you're walking
down this hallway his would have been
the last stall
before you get to the wash stalls
now is that the area that you were in
when you had that conversation with the
defendant yes sir
did he
come and approach you or or did you go
and approach him
so he came and approached me
and do you remember approximately
what day that was
it would have been on either like friday
or saturday it was late in the evening
when that happened
do you recall
generally what the defendant asked you
or said to you
yes
the conversation started out just
generally about what was going on and
then he asked me if i had brought my gun
with me on this trip and i said i had he
wanted to see it had he ever asked you
to see your gun before he had not asked
me to see it we had talked about it but
he had not asked to actually see it
before
what did you do after he asked you that
uh he wanted to see it so uh i got the
gun from my car in the case that you saw
here
and we looked at it and where did you
look at it with the defendant in front
of don de gaulle stall was anyone else
in the area at that time no sir there
were not
you said that that was at nighttime it
was late in the evening
can you
give an approximate time when you say
late in the evening what does that mean
around midnight or after
did he know where the handgun was or did
he just ask you to go get it
well how would he know that
that's what i'm asking you mean if he
said anything about it like go get it
from the car or word sonata
did he yes i'll rephrase the question
judge
please do that did he ask you
specifically to go get it out of the car
yes
when you brought it back in you
had said that it was still in that case
yes sir and were the
two magazines in the case with it yes
the orange plastic clip was in the uh
handgun itself yes sir
and i think you said that uh
possibly one of the clips was fully
loaded yes do you recall how much
ammunition or how many bullets
one of those
magazines held seven
but your recollection is that one of
them would have been empty
it could have been empty or it could
have just had one or two bullets in it
did he give you the handgun back after
he looked at it no sir he did not did he
open the case
and look at the handgun itself or did he
just look at the case
we just we looked at the case and opened
it up to see the handgun and then closed
it back up
do you remember if he took the handgun
out of the case at all no
he did not take it out of the case
did you see uh where he took it
specifically yes sir he took it into
uh
the club room
did you watch where he went from there
no sir i did not
did he tell you what he was going to do
with it no sir he did not did you ask
him what he was going to do no sir i did
not did you have any concerns with
giving it to him at that time absolutely
sir i did not at that time
now i'll draw your attention uh to
august 7th which is a wednesday
do you remember what you were doing let
me ask you this were you still at the
farm on wednesday august 7th yes sir i
was and you recall what you were doing
that morning yes sir um i was at that
long table that we had talked about
before i was sitting at the end of the
long table that was next to the front
windows doing some work on my
computer my laptop
mr shellhorn yes
do you know how much longer you're going
to be approximately
uh
10 to 15 minutes so i could either
finish now or i could
well it's 4 35 now
i think either way we'll probably need
tomorrow anyway so we've got to do folks
but i don't anticipate taking a long
time to finish with i don't i don't want
to go too much over it was just five
minutes or so i'd say we could finish
but
um
but i don't want to make any problems no
i understand all right ladies and
gentlemen i i think we'll take our um
evening recess now it's a little bit
past 4 30
and um
there may be days when we stay a little
bit later to finish up but um
it's too early in the trial to push it
so um
we'll break now we'll come back tomorrow
please be here around 8 30 or so so we
can get started as close to nine as
possible all right please don't discuss
the case have a good evening everyone
we'll see you tomorrow thank you
sure you can step down um dr cox we'll
see you tomorrow morning okay thank you
all right so i'm sure mr shelton may
want to speak to you but we'll figure
we'll get started close to nine o'clock
so
maybe 8 30. all right we'll see you then
i see you again
officer officer officer just have her
stay down here until the jurors leave if
you want
it's dr cox
mr shellhorn who's uh what's the batting
order for tomorrow
anticipate we would finish with dr uh dr
cox yes um i have vanessa medrano cortez
the dcp p worker is slated to be here in
the morning and i anticipate ms canara
will be called tomorrow okay all right
very good thank you
oh judge
mr bennett just reminded me i didn't
want to uh
give
mr harden and ms gray the okay to be
released
uh
i think they're finished at this point
so i was going to tell them they're free
to
travel back to florida and if there's a
need to recall them by the defense i
assume they'll make those arrangements
all right yeah i think that's the best
way to proceed especially since we're in
the middle of dr cox's testimony and
we're going to hear from ms canorack
do we have an estimate as to when
you're going to finish
judge based on where we are right now
somewhat dependent on cross-examination
obviously of course
i can make the representation of the
course that the doctor from the hospital
has office days on mondays and thursdays
so he had asked so he didn't have to
postpone any surgeries
or operations which would be on tuesdays
wednesdays or fridays if he could be
called on one of those two days on on
what days
if he could be called on a monday or a
thursday so i have him on standby i have
him here for thursday
assuming that
and where does he work at morristown
memorial
and so i i guess my point point being if
we don't get to him on thursday my
anticipation will be i would at least
need to call him on monday
uh all right well we'll probably get to
him um
we'll try to fit him in on thursday
if we have to take him a little bit out
of water we'll take him a little bit out
of order just to get it finished
should i tell him uh
i'll coordinate that discoordinate tell
him tell him thursday and
we'll see where we stand tomorrow at
close of business to see who's on the
stand and how much longer we anticipate
things going yes
but i don't anticipate beyond that i
think i only have
three other witnesses
so
probably won't finish this week but
maybe early next week i think we'll be
very close to finishing this week yeah
well again it depends on the
cross-examination
of the witnesses but either at the end
of this week or early next week
all right but we'll try to get the
doctor in on
on thursday
can i collect this evidence yes go ahead
all right mr grosso have all the jurors
left
all right very good
people observing the trial can now leave
we'll see you tomorrow
you